bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne l'audition d'yves jégo le
secrétaire d'état à l'outre-mer il a été
entendu hier soir par les sénateurs de
la mission d'information du sénat sur
l'autre au maire je vous rappelle qu'en
parallèle des états généraux de
l'outre-mer
les sénateurs ont souhaité rendre leur
propre rapport d'information sur la
situation dans les dom
la mission a effectué plusieurs
déplacements elle s'est rendue à la
réunion en guadeloupe ou en martinique
mais également en guyane sur place elle
a rencontré de nombreux acteurs sur les
thèmes de l'emploi de l'environnement du
logement
elle a également évoqué la situation
financière de ces départements autant de
thèmes qui ont été abordés hier soir à
l'occasion de l'audition d'yves jégo
tout de suite donc direction la salle
clemenceau pour cette audition bon
monsieur le ministre collègues dames et
messieurs
monsieur le ministre vous remercions
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
comme vous le savez nous avons fait un
long voyage sont connus comme ulysse
l'épreuve après avoir visité toi tour
l'a successivement la réunion la
guadeloupe la martinique la règle à
liane
nous sommes venus avec un certain nombre
de choses dès 6 ans et devront bien
échanger avec vous ce matin nous avons
la première course le premier constat
est là on la met un petit peut subodorer
l'occasion de débattre lodeom il s'agit
bien des outre-mer parce
qu'effectivement et comme l'a souligné
avaient souillé souvent les deux
collègues de la guyane nous avons des
îles qui ont certes beaucoup de choses
en commun mais qui aussi ont des
particularités bien à elle qu'il
faudrait
il faut des preuves entre autres alors
nous avons si vous voulez articuler
notre toute démarche autour de quatre
thèmes c'était même le des finances
locales
la continuité territoriale et ses
actions de la zone
la jeunesse dans la gouvernance toute
chose qui est toutes choses bien bien
bien vus revus dans nos différents
départements et si vous le voulez bien
pour l'organisation de nos débats ajouté
la parole pour faire rapidement un état
des lieux
et puis après quoi elle monsieur le
rapporteur de ligier vous posera
certaines des questions et puis de
longwy le débat avec deux autres cols
collègues
alors je vous passe la parole prend pour
10 15 milles messieurs le ministre puis
ensuite après coup dans le nez merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci de
m'accueillir je mesure l'importance des
travaux qui est celui de votre qui sont
ceux de votre commission de votre
implication si effectivement ce long
voyage que vous et vos pieds vous a je
crois permis de mieux appréhender les
réalités et de mieux découvrir sans
doute pour certains ou de mieux
comprendre pour tous les réalités de nos
outre mer je crois que vous avez raison
d'insister c'est le premier chose que je
voudrais développer devant vous sur la
diversité des situations et sur la
difficulté qu'il y à 2 comparé la
situation de la guyane avec celle de la
réunion de comparer la situation de
saint martin avec wallis et futuna ou de
comparer les 115 îles de la polynésie
française avec saint pierre et miquelon
il ya dans l'appellation outre-mer
évidemment une unité qui est celle de la
république et de nos devoirs vis-à-vis
de ces territoires mais aussi une
diversité géographique local de taille
de circonstance qui est tout à fait
considérable et qui doit à mon sens
mieux éclairer les politiques publiques
de l'avenir je pense que une des clés de
l'avenir est sans doute de trouver la
forme pour garantir l'unité républicaine
mais permettre à chaque territoire un
développement harmonieux fondée sur ces
réalités propres et sur ces réalités qui
ne sont pas les mêmes partout je sais et
l'histoire nous est clair que le grand
combat de la départementalisation de
l'après-guerre a amené à ce que l'idée
de droit commun soit une idée forte et
il faut y être attaché mais je crois que
une des clés pour l'évolution c'est
aussi que le droit commun doit savoir
s'adapter à la diversité et qu'il y ait
des politiques publiques qui ne peuvent
pas à l'évidence se décliner de la même
manière sur chacun de nos territoires
quels que soient l'attachement qu'on est
à l'unité de la république et aux règles
constitutionnelles qui fait que chacun
de nos compatriotes doit être traité de
la même manière il y ait là évidemment
une réalité géographique très forte
peut-être même encore plus forte
aujourd'hui dans ce monde plus ouvert
plus mobile qu'elle n'était au préalable
en votre mission
évidemment rentrer dans une logique qu'a
souhaité le président de la république
et le gouvernement après la crise qui a
frappé les antilles et dans une moindre
mesure l'océan indien à crise dont
chacun a pu mesurer qu'elle n'était pas
seulement une crise sociale mais qu'elle
était une crise plus profonde une crise
de société une crise de deux modèles
et crise qui nous oblige à porter à la
fois des réponses de court terme c'est
ce qui a été fait notamment dans le
cadre des accords qu'on peut être signée
territoire par territoire
c'est ce qui a été fait aussi dans le
cadre du texte que nous avons examiné la
loi de développement économique des
outre mer qui jette à la fois à certains
les bases d'un nouveau modèle économique
y qui prend des décisions qui vont
s'appliquer immédiatement
mais que ces décisions de court terme
ces décisions de réponse conjoncturelle
doivent se tenir et doivent prendre
place dans un cadre d'évolution
structurelles peut être plus ambitieux
plus lourd et que ce cadre doit se
fonder sur une réflexion partagée
réflexion de la haute assemblée travail
fait évidemment par les pouvoirs publics
mais aussi réflexion fondée sur les
états généraux de l'outre-mer qui sont
vous avez pu le constater dans votre
aide dans vos déplacements aujourd'hui
un des sujets d'actualité qui sont un
exercice original qui n'a jamais eu lieu
sous cette forme en tout cas récemment
c'est un exercice d'intelligence
partagée
c'est un exercice sans tabou sans a
priori avec une volonté du gouvernement
de fixer un cadre pour que chacun puisse
exprimer mais que ce cadre soit
tellement souple qu'il soit simplement
de support à l'émergence de propositions
de projets de forme à nouveau pour que
le nouveau modèle de société auquel
aspirent nos compatriotes et qui est
devenue aujourd'hui indispensable puisse
se fonder sur cette réflexion collective
évidemment vos travaux rentreront dans
ce cadre là je vous rappelle très
brièvement le calendrier de ces états
généraux jusqu'à la fin du mois de
juillet ce sont des débats sur le
terrain et des débats tous azimuts avec
notamment un support internet qui permet
un débat semble sans tabou et et le plus
plus anonyme possible pour ceux qui le
souhaitent ce sera ensuite au mois de
septembre une synthèse nationale qui
prendra en compte et
damman les l'ensemble des propositions
qui en fera exercice difficile dont on
sait qu'il sera difficile la synthèse
pour en tirer des politiques publiques
nouvelles qui seront alors à l'ordre du
jour d'un conseil interministériel de
l'outre-mer si j'ose dire d'un premier
conseil interministériel de l'outre-mer
qui se tiendra au mois d'octobre et qui
prendra des décisions qui éventuellement
ouvrir à de nouveaux champs législatif
pour que nous puissions avoir assuré que
le travail fait
par les uns et par les autres trouvera
une conclusion évidemment je souhaite
relever à 7 à ce niveau sur les états
généraux que les conclusions ne seront
pas uniquement législatives et d'autres
gouvernementale que c'est la société
tout entière qui devrait être mis en
mouvement et qu'il y aura sans doute des
décisions à prendre pour tous les
acteurs du développement d outre mer que
ce soit les acteurs économiques que ce
soit les partenaires sociaux que ce soit
les acteurs associatifs je n'imagine pas
qu'il suffise d'une loi ou d'une
enveloppe budgétaire aussi hausse qui
travaillait sous et elle pour changer le
modèle c'est évidemment une société qui
doit s'emparer de ce débat comme elle a
commencé à le faire depuis le démarrage
le 22 avril des états généraux
et comment comment elle va poursuivre
et vos travaux étant une partie
évidemment importante de cette réflexion
vous avez choisi de vous concentrer sur
un certain nombre de sujets qui sont
extrêmement importantes sur les
questions de finances locales sur les
questions de continuité territoriale et
d'insertion régionale de jeunesse de
gouverneur je crois que ça fait partie
effectivement des sujets majeurs
même si n'épuise pas à eux seuls la
vaste question des autres maires et de
leur avenir mais ce sont les sujets
majeurs
le gouvernement a dans le même temps
lancé un certain nombre de
d'action pour éclairer aussi ces états
généraux et et ses débats j'ai saisi la
haute autorité de la concurrence qui
doit me remettre avant l'été un avis sur
l'exercice la concurrence dans les
départements d'outre-mer et plus
particulièrement sur les carburants et
les mécanismes d'importation et
distribution des produits de grande
consommation c'est un sujet majeur sur
lequel on a besoin d'avoir tous les
éclairages possible pour pouvoir évoluer
nous avons mis en place des mesures et
j'ai demandé à l'insee d'approfondir un
travail sur la comparatif des
indicateurs on a une grande difficulté à
voir des indicateurs fiables d'évolution
de coût de la vie est comparable avec
ceux de la métropole on entend beaucoup
de choses on a chacun son approche des
choses mais lindsay est au travail
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois pour
créer ces indicateurs que j'appelle de
différentiel de coût de la vie qui
permettrait de mesurer très exactement
entre les outre mer et la métropole la
réalité des choses en prenant en compte
la totalité des problématiques qui dit
coût de la vie c'est pas seulement
l'alimentation dans les grandes surfaces
ou des produits de première nécessité
c'est le poste logement c'est les
questions qui sont liées au chauffage
qui soumis aux modes de vie qui doivent
être pris en compte
on a besoin et l'insee travaille sur cet
indicateur qui devrait être disponible
dès la mi 2010 sur ces sujets là et
chacun engagés en particulier le
secrétariat d'état à l'outre-mer un
certain nombre de réflexions de
rencontre moi même je présiderai cinq
rencontres rue oudinot avec des
personnalités qualifiées et
et des ministres du gouvernement la
première aura lieu le 3 juin prochain
avec martin hirsch sur les questions qui
sont liées à la jeunesse une jeunesse
nombreuse est ce que c'est une chance ou
un défi insurmontable on l'a bien un
sujet sur lequel évidemment nous
souhaitons si en mobilisant des
personnalités concernées et bien
apporter notre pierre les autres
réunions de ces matinales de la rue
oudinot concerneront les relations entre
la métropole et ses outre-mer le regard
croisé qui est nécessaire pour changer
de regard sur l'outre-mer le dialogue
social est ce que c'est une mission
impossible que de refonder le dialogue
social
l'aménagement et le développement
durable le défi de l'insularité est un
défi considérable dont vous avez pu je
pense mesurer la réalité physique et qui
offre des opportunités mais aussi des
contraintes tout à fait considérable et
enfin la cinquième des matinales du dino
sera consacré à la culture et l'histoire
au service de l'avenir
vous voyez que nous souhaitons en
mobilisant des intellectuels des
personnalités des universitaires des
élus en mobilisant les ministres du
gouvernement participé aussi à faire
émerger les propositions qui nous
permettront de bâtir sur ces grandes
thématiques
le nouveau modèle qui est attendu alors
sur les questions plus transversales que
vous avez choisi il ya évidemment un
défi majeur qui est celui de la jeunesse
une des caractéristiques de notre mère
et que sa jeunesse y est nombreuse
d'ailleurs il faut noter et c'est tout à
fait important que la bonne tenue de
notre pays en matière de natalité est
due en grande partie à la vitalité de
l'autre mère et que le nombre de
naissances de nos dans nos
départements et collectivités
d'outre-mer qui est supérieur en
proportion à la proportion que
représente la population est aussi un
des éléments de la tenue du
développement démographique de notre
pays qui est un atout vu de là quand on
le regarde à l'échelon macro économique
de notre pays et qui est un inconvénient
vue sur un territoire restreint
évidemment qui nous oblige à décliner
des politiques publiques tout à fait
particulière le gouvernement a déjà sans
vouloir évidemment épuisé le sujet
mobilise et un certain nombre d'outils
le premier c'est celui du service
militaire adapté qui est un outil
d'insertion qui a fait ses preuves qui a
maintenant presque 50 ans d'existence et
qui permet de mobiliser les moyens
militaires pour former des jeunes en
grande difficulté
non seulement au savoir faire qui est
nécessaire pour leur vie professionnelle
mais aussi au savoir être et la
formation militaire rapporte ce bénéfice
le président de la république a annoncé
que nous allons passer de 3000 à 6000
places offertes pour les jeunes en
service militaire adapté
c'est un premier effort c'est un premier
outil le deuxième outil au service de la
jeunesse cette fois-ci formé de la
jeunesse plus diplômés c'est la réforme
de notre opérateur qui hélas nt où
l'avait votée dans la loi de
développement économique de l'outre-mer
nous allons transformer en profondeur la
mt pour en faire une agence de la
mobilité une agence de la formation en
mobilité
et pour mettre en place des programmes
spécifiques notamment un programme
spécifique adaptée aux jeunes diplômés
pour permettre à des jeunes diplômés de
pouvoir s'insérer ça sert évidemment
localement c'est l'idéal mais ça serait
aussi nationalement ou
internationalement c'est aussi une des
voies très forte de formation de notre
pays où nous avons un programme sur 1500
cadres
enfin jeunes diplômés futurs cadres en
soutien avec la mt enfin
les politiques d'insertion sur les
jeunes elle passe aussi par une
mobilisation d'un fonds
d'expérimentation innovants et donc nous
avons vous avez voté dans la lodeom une
enveloppe un fonds qui doit nous
permettre aussi et je reviens à l'idée
de diversité que j'évoquais dans le
début de mon propos d'expérimenter des
politiques publiques de formation et
d'insertion en faveur de la jeunesse qui
ne sont d'ailleurs pas forcément les
mêmes d'un territoire à un autre mais
qui doivent nous permettre de voir quels
sont les dispositifs les plus adaptés à
cette question majeure
évidemment je n'oublie pas mais vous
aurez peut-être l'occasion de
l'auditionner la question de l'éducation
nationale
l'effort que le ministère de l'éducation
nationale doit faire sur nos salma
l'effort éducatif traditionnel mais
aussi l'adaptation de ces outils a des
spécificités je pense en particulier à
la guyane on ne peut pas continuer de
raisonner quand on est très loin sur le
yapo coup sur le maroni
avec les mêmes raisonnements d'enfants
seulement à 5 heures du matin à la
prendre une pirogue revenant dans une
école où il n'y a pas forcément une
restauration scolaire et rentrant chez
eux l'après midi dans des conditions
épouvantables
je crois qu'il faut la développer des
mesures de télé-enseignement de
d'utilisation des moyens modernes
d'enseignement qu'il faut que nous
fassions oeuvre d'imagination pour
adapter les outils de l'éducation à des
réalités physiques qui sont des réalités
tout à fait particulière et je pense
qu'il y aura peut-être dans l'audition
que vous aurez 2010 l'éducation
nationale vraiment un sujet majeur sur
ces questions de jeunesse sur ces
questions d'insertion professionnelle
qui doivent nous mobiliser le deuxième
thème avant de répondre à vos questions
c'est évidemment le thème de continuité
territoriale et d'assertions régional
vous avez bien fait de l'ailier parce
qu'ils sont très liés moi je suis
persuadé après 14 mois de responsabilité
sur les questions ultra marines que
l'avenir de l'outre-mer et que le
nouveau modèle passe d'abord et
peut-être même avant tout en tout cas
avec la même la même puissance par une
meilleure insertion dans le tissu
régional l'avenir de la caraïbes
françaises se situent dans le
développement de nos relations avec le
reste de la caraïbe
l'avenir de la guyane se situe sans
doute dans une insertion plus grande
dans son tissu amazonien et dans ses
liens avec des grands pays voisins
notamment le brésil l'avenir de mayotte
et de la réunion passe par une meilleure
insertion dans l'océan indien est
évidemment dans le pacifique par des
liens plus forts avec les grands pays
voisins je pense naturellement à
l'australie pour ce qui est de la
nouvelle calédonie et wallis et futuna
qui doivent être prises en compte alors
comment ce cette coopération régionale
peut être renforcée d'abord avec deux
axes forts me semble-t-il celui de la
continuité des liaisons territoriales on
ne peut pas continuer d'avoir les
difficultés qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
sur les liaisons ne serait ce qu'entre
les îles du sud de la guadeloupe et la
guadeloupe qui sont pour le moins pour
le moins difficile
est très coûteuse il faut vraiment que
nous puissions nous posait les questions
et moi je souhaite qu'il y ait un schéma
de continuité territoriale régionale
qu'ils soient mises en place et que les
liaisons qui puisse être faite entre les
différents territoires et leurs voisins
est immédiate soit vraiment travaillé au
titre de d'un service public de
continuité territoriale qui à partir du
moment où il va permettre un meilleur
rayonnement sur l'environnement régional
va permettre les échanges le
développement de l'activité économique
de l'activité touristique qui va
permettre de mieux inscrire ces
territoires dans une logique de
proximité
je le dis souvent sous le ton de
l'anecdote mais il m'a fallu plusieurs
mois au secrétariat d'état à l'outre-mer
pour chaque déplacement pour obtenir
dans mes dossiers de déplacement autre
chose qu'une carte du territoire dans
lequel je me rendais mais une carte de
la région et il n'y avait pas de format
de carte qui permettait quand on allait
se rendre en martinique ou en guadeloupe
d'avoir une vision un peu plus large de
voir ce qu'il y avait autour si j'ose
dire
pour parler de façon triviale évidemment
je pense que cette ouverture sur sur la
coopération régionale est importante
ça veut dire continuité territoriale ça
veut dire un travail de mise à plat des
dispositifs existants je prendrai qu'un
exemple que vous n'avez pas visité qui
celui de wallis et futuna wallis et
futuna son sont deux il a peu éloignées
l'une de l'autre qui bénéficie d'une
liaison avec un avion entre les deux
îles et qui sont reliés à peu près
traditionnellement est naturellement
avec la nouvelle calédonie ce qui semble
logique parce que c'est le territoire
national le plus proche
sauf que wallis et futuna pourrait être
relié à fidji qui est le grand hub
aéroportuaire du secteur et qu'il n'y a
pas pour l'instant de liaisons
régulières qui pourrait amener les
wallisiens et futuniens vers siggi et
que pour repartir en europe bien souvent
il faut qu'ils aillent à nouméa dans des
conditions financières et de
déplacements qui sont évidemment
incohérent voilà un petit exemple qui
qui qui m'est apparu lors d'un
déplacement à wallis et futuna qui
montre on a absolument besoin de schéma
de cohérence et de continuité
territoriale et de développer les
notions de service public de continuité
territoriale
alex yeux à l'échelon régional bien sûr
mais évidemment la continuité
territoriale c'est aussi une
problématique plus lourde de lien avec
la métropole de prix de billets d'avion
le gouvernement travaille d'ailleurs
actuellement sur une extension des
obligations de service public à
destination des compagnies aériennes
pour que nous puissions mettre en oeuvre
la politique tarifaire qui était votée
dans la lodeom et avoir des conditions
de desserte qui soient les plus
avantageuses possible cette question de
la continuité territoriale sur
l'insertion régionale elle se double
d'un autre sujet c'est celui comment
dire de l'harmonie légistatives de ces
territoires notamment en matière
économique
hélas il y à un sujet tout à fait
important je rencontre encore hier des
chefs d'entreprise de guadeloupe qui
développe une activité qui pourrait
s'ouvrir sur les 32 millions de
consommateurs de la caraïbe puisque la
caraïbe de cuba en tout cas 2002 du sud
des états unis jusqu'au venezuela
c'est un chapelet de 32 millions
d'habitants et qu'ils seraient
évidemment à des législations
différentes et à une insécurité
juridique qui ne permet pas ces échanges
crois qu'il ya là sans doute une
réflexion sur l'harmonisation sur les
conditions dans lesquelles on pourrait
sécuriser le
les échanges économiques qui auraient
des vertus dans dans les deux sens alors
des vertus d'approvisionnement à moindre
coût peut être de nos territoires en
matière d'importation mais aussi des
vertus d'exportation de savoir faire
dans des conditions renforcer la
réflexion sur le devenir régional elle
s'ouvre sur bien d'autres sujets celui
des universités par exemple pense que
nos universités gagnerait à devenir des
universités à vocation régionale qu'on
gagnerait à transformer l'université de
la réunion en université francophone de
l'océan indien ou à transformer la
l'université antilles guyane en
université francophone de la caraïbe et
pourquoi pas avoir parallèlement
universités franco-brésilienne de guyane
l'ouverture aux échanges c'est aussi
l'insertion des jeunes c'est aussi la
formation des jeunes c'est aussi cette
réalité qui fait que dans un monde
globalisé
on ne peut pas continuer à un réseau à
raisonner uniquement dans un lien quasi
binaire métropole territoire qu'il faut
ouvrir le développement au secteur
environnant et inscrire ces territoires
dans leur dans leurs perspectives
d'environnement quelques mots mais je
pense que les questions seront
importantes sur les questions de
finances locales vous avez pu voir que
manifestement c'était une question
majeure qu'il y avait une problématique
des collectivités locales qui était tout
à fait particulière que pour dire les
choses très clairement les collectivités
locales ont des difficultés financières
considérables et que nous devons à mon
sens engagé une réforme des finances
locales d'outre-mer pour adapter les
moyens de l'état aux besoins des
collectivités locales peut être aussi et
ça m'ouvre sur le sujet de la
gouvernance pour rationaliser
l'organisation des collectivités locales
c'est vrai que comme sur un même
territoire vous avez 24 communes cinq
intercommunalités un conseil général et
un conseil régional qui gère le même
territoire et une population de 300 ou
400 mille habitants il ya peut-être des
échelons sur lesquels on peut travailler
en matière de rationalisation ayant tout
cas une approche du financement des
collectivités locales qui doit être
évoquée avec des questions qu'il faut
ouvrir celle de l'octroi de mer dont
vous savez que l'europe a mis une
barrière alors tout cas pour rouvrir des
négociations qui à 2014
comment faut-il faire soit survivre à
l'octroi de mer soit avoir un autre
source de financement pour les
collectivités locales
comment avoir des dotations qui prennent
en compte des difficultés géographiques
particulières la commune de maripa soula
à la surface géographique de l'île de
france
comment peut-on ne pas essayer
évidemment d'avoir des dotations des
conditions qui soient particulière je
crois qu'il ya un sujet majeur
je vous dis d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement attend avec beaucoup
d'intérêt vos propositions les
propositions du sénat sur ce sujet là
pour trouver la meilleure formule
évidemment il ya un débat qu'il n'a pas
pu vous échapper qui est celui de la
gouvernance qui est peut-être celui qui
dans l'opinion publique
que et le plus et le plus prégnant en
tout cas sur le site internet qui était
ouvert pour les états généraux de
l'outre-mer on s'aperçoit que ce thème
là et le thème le plus fréquenté le plus
sur lequel les internautes
il y à eut pas loin de 50 mille
visiteurs sur le site c'est sur ce
sujet-là qui s'expriment le plus c'est
peut-être sur celui-ci qu'au nom du
gouvernement je m'exprimerai le moins
non pas parce que je n'ai pas un avis
personnel mais pas ce que je souhaite
aussi respecter l'idée qu' il faut que
ces états généraux se déroule sans tabou
sans sens présupposés du gouvernement et
que la constitution en france sur les
questions de gouvernance plusieurs
modèles moi je souhaite vraiment que ce
soit des débats locaux qui puissent
fixer sur ces questions de gouvernance
le meilleur modèle vu du point de vue
des élus locaux du point de vue de
l'état nous aurons un chantier majeur à
ouvrir qui est celui de la
réorganisation des services de l'état
dans les territoires
je pense que l'état doit être vis-à-vis
de l'outre-mer à la fois stratège et et
fixer des orientations et des a fixé le
cap mais il doit être aussi régulateurs
et que pour être régulateur il faut que
les services de l'état se réorganise en
profondeur on ne peut pas plaquer le
modèle métropolitain d'organisation des
préfectures de région des sous
préfectures des préfectures de
département sur le modèle insulaire il
faut donc que nous fassions ce travail
avec un objectif c'est de rendre les
services de l'état plus efficace
là où ils sont attendus c'est à dire
pour le contrôle pour la régulation pour
la vérification de la bonne application
des politiques publiques
et puis pour le maintien de l'équité
républicaine qui évidemment est un sujet
qui doit être qui doit être au coeur des
préoccupations de l'état
il y a sans doute des réorganisations à
faire je suis assez sensible par exemple
pour ne donner qu'un exemple mais à
l'idée du préfet de guadeloupe
d'organiser une direction de la mer qui
regrouperait les différents services de
l'état en charge des questions maritimes
parce qu'évidemment qui dit insularité
dit aussi problématiques liées à la mer
quand on voit le travail qui est fait à
mayotte par exemple sur la coordination
des différents services de l'état au
service de la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière qui est un fléau important à
mayotte
là les services de l'état ont su
s'organiser créer une plate forme
commune mutualiser leurs moyens
faire en sorte que quand c'est pas le
bateau des douanes qui sortent c'est
celui de la gendarmerie quand c'est pas
celui de la gendarmerie
c'est celui de la police de l'air aux
frontières et que la bonne mutualisation
des services de l'état se met au service
d'une politique spécifique mais je crois
que sur la lutte contre les prix les
prix enfin la vie chère et pour la
baisse des prix je crois que dans un
certain nombre de domaines les services
de l'état doivent se réorganiser pour
assurer évidemment la régulation
nécessaires et le contrôle nécessaire
des politiques publiques la gouvernance
c'est pas seulement la façon dont on
gère les collectivités locales c'est
aussi la façon dont l'état gère ses
propres services faudra aussi sans doute
je l' ai déjà dit mais avoir une
réflexion au sein de de l'administration
centrale pour voir comment le
secrétariat d'état à l'outre-mer peut
rester une administration de mission
qu'elle est en train de devenir avec les
réformes que nous mettons en place une
administration de stratégie de
définition d'orientations d'évaluation
des politiques publiques
mais comment chacun des ministères doit
pouvoir se réapproprier les politiques
publiques en faveur de l'outre-mer
parce que ce n'est pas aux secrétaires
d'état à gérer la politique éducative
c'est aux ministres éducation nationale
en liaison avec le secrétariat d'état
qui peut qui peut aider sur ce sujet les
questions de gouvernance si j'ose dire
sont à tous les étages et évidemment le
gouvernement travaill ait réfléchi et
proposera en fonction de ce qui est
mènera des états généraux des pistes sur
ces questions majeures voilà un sujet
qui est loin d'être épuisé j'espère ne
pas avoir refusé le
les auditeurs où j'ai été trop longs
bâiller donné dix minutes j'ai fait plus
mais j'espère que par ce long préambule
je répare avance répondu à quelques
questions vous pouviez vous posez mais
on sera conduit à céder à jouer les
prolongations ce étonnement il ya un
système qui n'est pas abordé le ministre
ce que vous allez revenir certainement
plus tard c'est le thème des de
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
on vient tout à l'heure je parce que la
parole de tout de suite ah ben on va
repartir à porter mais après quoi nous
allons passer la parole à chaque groupe
politique
une déclaration et puis ensuite nous
allons vous le débat repart tabou bien
assez ouvert monsieur le porter oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre c'est vrai que vous avez
répondu probablement auparavant toutes
les questions mais je vais quand même me
permettre faire part de quelques
réflexions et puis peut-être vous poser
quelques questions vous avez dit tout
d'abord que vous étiez au ministère
depuis 14 mois que donc ça y est vous
étiez moi ça fait que deux mois que j'ai
cette responsabilité très éphémère deux
rapporteurs donc excusé éventuellement
la non mise en ordre de ma réflexion
mais ça viendra progressivement lorsque
le rapport s'établir et on vous fera un
certain nombre de propositions qui sera
qui seront organisées donc je serai
peut-être un peu schématique là vous
dire aussi qu'au retour de la mission
j'ai pas tout à fait la même vision que
celle que j'avais au départ d'intérêt en
tout cas pour moi de la mission mais je
crois que c'est vrai pour l'ensemble des
membres même ceux de l'outre-mer
si on peut découvrir d'autres
territoires que ceux sur lesquels ils
sont habituellement mais je dois dire
aussi que si j'avais été rapporteur de
la lodeom
après la mission plutôt qu'avant
j'aurais peut-être changer quelque peu
mes positions sur certains sujets enfin
cette réflexion personnelle et qu'on
aurait pu aller un peu plus loin dans le
débat bien ceux ci ceci étant dit je
voudrais dire quand même un certain
nombre de réflexions pour en arriver à
mes questions
effectivement on a pu découvrir les
spécificités des outre-mer je pense que
ça a été assez criant pour nous tous
durant cette mission et on a eu un
manque
enfin une vision et confirmation d'un
manque d'évaluation par l'ensemble des
services de l'état avec un travail
transversal qui n'est pas fait c'est à
dire que chaque service de l'état a une
connaissance claire des secteurs qui les
concerne la fiscalité l'insee les
services divers et variés que l'on a pu
rencontrer le rectorat l'inspection
d'académie etc
mais on a vraiment le sentiment que la
vision transversale pour n'existe pas ni
au niveau local ni au niveau national
d'ailleurs vous l'avais un peu dit dans
vos propos niveau national qu'il
faudrait revoir la gouvernance et je
dois dire que cela choque quelque peu de
voir que ce problème de l'évaluation
n'est pas faite localement et que bien
évidemment partir du moment où
l'évaluation n'est pas faite et qu'elle
n'est pas bien remonter ou bien comprise
au niveau central et bien on peut pas
prendre les bonnes dispositions au
niveau au niveau politique et que cela
peut conduire
toujours et encore et bien de la
défiscalisation et les financements à
des aides qui ne sont pas d'ailleurs les
questions que l'on nous a posé le plus
souvent au niveau local on nous a posé
bien d'autres bien d'autres questions
dont ce problème là est un vrai problème
vous nous avez parlé également du
problème du financement des
collectivités locales
non c'est un sujet qui est apparu assez
vite comme étant un vrai problème est là
encore on a eu le sentiment qu'il
fallait plutôt tirer les vers du nez
excusez moi l'expression d'un certain
nombre d un de nos interlocuteurs pour
aller voir jusqu'où était la réalité des
difficultés des collectivités locales
principalement des communes bien sûr des
intercommunalités mais des communes 10
pour mes collègues ne se sera mis dans
le rapport avec des chiffres la quasi
totalité des communes à lorient n'a pas
beaucoup des communes entre 20 et 30 en
gros par département je rappelle que
dans un département équivalent français
y en a 300 quand il y en a 30 au niveau
de l'outre-mer la plupart ont des
difficultés considérables dont 80 % de
frais de personnel et non pas de
capacités bien sûr d'investissement et
l'autofinancement est par ailleurs ne
payent pas leurs charges sociales bien
souvent mais non seulement les charges
sociale légale si j'ose dire mais aussi
les charges sociales salariales et
patronales
donc les retient les concerne donc ça
pose quand même des problèmes assez
considérable et on a bien vu qu'il y
avait de temps en temps un regard
pudique locales sur ces questions là
donc on ne peut pas continuer et j'étais
heureux de vous entendre dire seul
ministre qu'il fallait en l'occurrence
véritablement prendre cette chose à bras
le corps et remettent les choses au
clair par continuer à partir sur des
mauvaises mauvaises bases également bien
évidemment ce problème de la formation
des prix
quand même regrettable parce que c'est
pas nouveau que finalement on est auto
de difficultés à avoir les choses
clairement et plus on rencontrait
d'interlocuteurs transporteurs port
autonome dans ce grand magasin petits
commerçants plus la clarté se pacifier
c'est à dire qu'on n'arrivait pas à y
voir clair et je pense qu'on va avoir
alors on ne citera pas nos sources mais
il ya des études qui ont été faites sur
le sujet et vous pense qu'on aura
vraiment une démonstration assez
précises dans les jours qui viennent sur
la composition d'un certain nombre de
prix qui devraient nous éclairer
également un sujet vous avez peut-être
abordé mais de façon très très légère
dans le cadre de l'insertion régionale
c'est véritablement la manière
dont sont appliquées les règlements
français et européens dans des
territoires qui ne sont pas du tout
adaptés à ce type de règlement dans y'a
pas tous mais dans un certain nombre
ça nous a quand même totalement surpris
avec des exemples extrêmement précis de
voir que l'on appliquait au fin fond de
la forêt amazonienne exactement les
mêmes règles que dans une commune de la
région parisienne alors que c'est
totalement impossible donne un exemple
qu'on a du jus qui nous a frappés
religieux au milieu de la forêt
guyanaise on dit si quelqu'un se blesse
ou appeler le 18 faut appeler les
pompiers
bon donc ça fait rire tout le monde mais
c'est dramatique
quand on voit qu'on est obligé de voir
ce type de règlement appliqué alors bien
évidemment c'est impossible comme s'est
appliqué par les fonctionnaires français
localement bien évidemment il donne des
leçons aux locaux en leur disant comment
vous n'appelez pas les pompiers enfin
bref
donc c'est pour vous dire qu'il ya un
déphasage total entre la réalité
hexagonal et la réalité locale et qu'il
faut absolument que l'on fasse un
travail important sur les normes et les
rênes et l'on peut en venir à l'octroi
de mer c'est vrai que c'est un sujet qui
a été abordé kiki qui inquiète qui
paniquent localement parce
qu'effectivement avec nous
vision métropolitaine bien évidemment
l'octroi de mer est un sujet qui n'est
pas notre préoccupation quotidienne au
niveau métropolitain
mais au niveau de l'outre-mer c'est bien
évidemment une inquiétude majeure et il
faut clarifier rapidement et avoir une
action à mon avis très forte auprès de
bruxelles
en ayant une position claire au niveau
national on savoir ce que l'on veut et
ce que l'on présente au niveau de
bruxelles
on veut plus de l'octroi de mer et on le
dit où on en veut et on se bat pour
défendre l'octroi de mer sinon on va
arriver dans une impasse dans quelques
mois d'ailleurs notre visite à bruxelles
a été assez éloquente en la matière donc
le développement de gênes ça nous paraît
quelque chose d'essentiel
je ne vois pas comment ces territoires
en dehors de toutes les politiques que
l'on met en place pourront véritablement
avoir un avenir un véritable avenir s'il
n'ya pas de développement de jay or ce
que l'on a
enfin bien sûr les les habitants
d'outre-mer le savez bien sûr les élus
mais ce que l'on a pu voir c'est qu'il y
avait des capacités dans certains
domaines qui étaient considérables en
matière de développement endogène et que
l'organisation des filières par exemple
n'était pas au point
donc c'est un vrai sujet comment
organiser les filières mais je pense
qu'on a un rôle à jouer en la matière
d'autant plus à chaque fois qu'on parle
de ces sujets là sont pas des sujets
insurmontable on raisonne à l'échelle de
trois cent mille habitants
cette fois à l'échelle de 30 millions
d'habitants donc c'est un sujet qui à
mon avis doit pouvoir être traités avec
une certaine intelligence
autre sujet c'est le plan minier alors
là les bras nous en sont tombés
j'ai pas eu l'honneur et le plaisir ce
que j'ai raté qu'une seule audition ici
même c'est celle du préfet qui est
chargé du plan minier
donc j'ai pas retenu son nom piment
n'était pas là voilà c'est ça bon alors
ici je pense la presse qu'on m'a dit que
tout le monde à venir
c'est vrai il a sûrement raison et
cetera quand on va là-bas il a
totalement tort donc on a là aussi si
vous voulez il ya il ya toujours géré l
envers du décor où on a vraiment le
sentiment elle ce qui s'était dit très
clairement localement en guyane c'est
con mais la guyane sous planche donc ça
nous a été dit par tous partout on nous
a dit la guyane à une richesse de sous
sol qui est considérable non ça on le
sait de l'or du diamant de l'uranium etc
sans parler potentiellement du pétrole
en mer et que finalement ils n'ont pas
le droit
très peu le droit de l'exploiter parce
que on a notre vision européenne
hexagonal de dire il faut nous protéger
cette belle forêt pour qu'on puisse
respirer en ile-de-france en solo gîte
pense que on sait bien d'où vient le
vent mais ceci étant dit il faut quand
même avoir une vraie réflexion sur le
sujet où on n'autorise pas les la guyane
a utilisé son sous-sol et à ce moment là
il faut assumer l'addition ou alors on
autorise d'utiliser le sous sol le sol
et l'espace parce que je rappelle quand
même si on prend simplement la guyane t
elle à sa richesse du sous-sol du sol
une forêt de la france et qui à l'espace
et qu'en réalité on n'a pas
véritablement une optimisation de tous
ces éléments dont une certitude en tout
cas c'est que ces territoires
quand on a un gros potentiel quelle que
soit la localisation
c'est à dire la réunion à la guyane en
passant par les antilles n'obtient gros
potentiel au précieux le ministre
quelques questions mais au travers de
mes réflexions chez sûr que vous avez
senti quelques questions quelques
interrogations que peut-être je t'ai
murray dans le rapport ou que je
traduirai différemment mais c'est
vraiment le le ressenti
donc est ce que vous avez est-ce que
vous pensez que qu'on a mis en place les
véritables outils d'évaluation et que
nos politiques sont le résultats
d'évaluation ou que ce sont plutôt la
nécessité de faire du conjoncturel
plutôt que de faire de la prospective
ensuite est-ce que vous pensez que
l'organisation
la rgpp ou l'organisation de votre
ministère alors là je veux plus encore
plus direct sous la coupe du ministère
de l'intérieur est une bonne
organisation et ce qu'il faudrait pas
une organisation plus transversale une
question qu'on peut se poser
parce que comme on voit que localement
on n'arrive pas à faire du transversale
est ce que ça vient pas du fait que
chacun remonte à son ministère au niveau
national donc est ce que c'est une une
réflexion que l'on a peu que l'on peut
aborder entre autres sujets un vrai
sujet c'est l'immigration vous l'avez
dit est ce que l'on doit avoir une
réflexion posée la question de
l'immigration est ce que l'immigration
doit être traitée dans un certain nombre
de territoires de la même manière
qu'elle est traitée sur un territoire de
l'hexagone
est ce qu'on doit avoir une réflexion
particulière va quand on est sur place
on se dit que c'est pas possible d'avoir
exactement les mêmes règles dans la
région parisienne pour prendre un autre
département
elvire le loiret mais je puise mon les
autres en tête mais quand on regarde ces
départements on se dit que vraiment si
on applique les mêmes règles
d'immigration ce qu'on n'a pas compris
la manière dont les choses se passent en
matière de scolarité vous l'avez dit
également transports scolaires mais
également en matière de scolarité
donc on vous mettra le nombre d'écoles
le nombre de lycées le nombre de
collèges qu'il faut fabriquer chaque
année en guyane puis à fareins ou pour
un sou j'exagère ils sont dédiés dans le
sous sol mais il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'argent on est obligé de construire
sans arrêt des établissements scolaires
est bon il n'y a pas de limite donc est
ce qu'il n'ya pas une organisation à
réfléchir
voilà monsieur le ministre un certain
nombre de vos réactions
donc l'intégration régionale j'en ai
parlé bien évidemment puis la
gouvernance locale joly dit peu de
communes départements et régions qui ont
exactement le même territoire
ça prouve quand même quelques quelques
problèmes à écouter ce qui peut être dit
localement par par les élus donc là une
réflexion qui est à mon avis mériterait
également d'être couchés plus rapidement
fusé moi d'avoir été un peu direct
monsieur le ministre mais il fallait pas
m'envoyer la base si elle n'est pas que
je réagisse quelque peu sur un certain
nombre de sujets que j'ai eu le plaisir
de partager avec mes collègues dans une
mission je tiens à le dire ce que je
sais pas s'il ya des ddd des
journalistes ici
nous étions six plus à chaque fois les
parlementaires locaux afin locaux les
trois qui venez nous rejoindre ou les
deux selon les départements donc on
était 6 + 2 ou 3 et et qu'on a bossé
bossé terriblement je tiens à dire aussi
on a dû avoir à peu près dix réunions
par jour pendant 12 jours donc je crois
que beaucoup peuvent en témoigner
je tenais à dire ça parce qu'il
paraîtrait que on était 42 sur place qui
bien évidemment n'est pas la réalité est
bien évidemment j'invite tous ceux qui
qui qui pensent pouvoir nous suivre à
venir avec nous quand on part des
placements via mon avis ils repassent
jusqu'au bout voilà je excuse moi sur le
président et ribéry n'a sûrement des
choses bonnes à prendre dans ce que je
dis et à une très bonne beaucoup de
bonnes choses mais je voulais des
poteaux suite ou bien je passe donc je
pense d'abord aux familles disent
allez-y
oui brièvement aussi beaucoup de sujets
que vous qu est évalué sur les
politiques d'évaluation
évidemment il ya un effort considérable
moi j'ai engagé il ya quelques mois la
réforme du ministère du secrétariat
d'état à l'outre-mer nous avons fusionné
en une seule délégation les deux
directions antérieur et la nouveauté de
cette mise en place de nouvelles
organisations et la création d'une
structure dédiée à l'évaluation des
politiques publiques alors elle se met
en place
depuis maintenant quelques mois elle a
pour vocation évidemment à l'échelon
central de pouvoir avoir les outils
d'évaluation qui manquent
il faut décliner ensuite ces outils
d'évaluation à l'échelon chaque
territoire et pour répondre à votre
question je pense qu'il ya des gros
progrès à faire en matière d'évaluation
des politiques publiques ce qui veut
dire aussi pour être traître est là
aussi très franc et sans langue de bois
qu'il faudra savoir dire comme des
publics politiques publiques ne
fonctionnent pas proposé de les réformer
de l'échangé de mettre fin à un certain
nombre de dispositifs et avoir aussi
cette cette idée là mais nous manquons
d'outils d'évaluation et c'est une des
stratégies que nous mettons en place
alors il ya évidemment des évaluations
ponctuelles quand on envoie une mission
sur le carburant comme nous l'avons fait
au mois de décembre on s'aperçoit que
après plusieurs mois le travail des
inspecteurs nous amène une carte et
qu'on n'avait pas forcément préalable
mais nous devrions avoir les outils
d'évaluation pérenne quotidien si j'ose
dire à l'échelon central mais aussi à
l'échelon local et je pense que dans les
réflexions sur la nouvelle organisation
des services de l'état il faut qu'il y
ait au côté des préfets une instance
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
qui à l'échelon des territoires
permettent de mesurer les et les ai
faits accomplis et de proposer des
adaptations des politiques publiques
parce que je reviens sur votre deuxième
remarque il est évidemment indispensable
d'adapter les politiques publiques c'est
déjà le cas vous avez parlé la politique
d'immigration il ya déjà un certain
nombre de règles particulières qui
s'appliquent sur l'autre mère mais sans
doute pas suffisante
moi je suis revenu des déplacements
comme les votes de la même manière je
pense qu'on ne peut pas dire que d'un
côté ou de l'autre du maroni en
immigrent on traverse le fleuve et que
la notion de traversée du fleuve c'est
pas une notion qu'on peut prendre en
considération de la même manière qu'eux
on traite un problème d'immigration
seine-et-marne où dans le
dans le loiret est-ce qu'il a subie à
une action internationale à mener
l'action il ya peut-être une forme de
statue ça a été le cas d'ailleurs du
côté du avec le surinam de statut qui
peut qui devrait pouvoir permettre à
ceux qui vivent de part et d'autre d'un
fleuve bas de traverser et et
fonctionner dans de bonnes conditions
c'est indispensable d'adapter les
politiques publiques
c'est indispensable de le faire à
l'échelon des politiques de l'état
c'est indispensable et ça me permet de
dire un mot aussi du schéma minier de
proposer comme je lé fais sur le schéma
minier que par une habilitation nous
habitions la collectivité locale a
décidé du schéma minier l'article la
constitution le permet c'est l'article
73 de la constitution qui permet aux
collectivités locales de demander d
habilitation législative d'ailleurs vous
avez voté dans la lodeom la première
habilitation législative demandé par la
guadeloupe sur des questions de
formation professionnelle être création
d'un établissement public de formation
professionnelle moi je serais très
ouvert à ce que par exemple la
collectivité de guyane demande une
habilitation législative pour gérer son
schéma minier
j'aurai une vision peut-être un peu
moins brutale sur le travail du préfet
m'en sion qui est un travail compliqué
mais je pense que effectivement c'est
plus peut-être à la collectivité de
guyane de déterminer son schéma minier
avec un avis de l'état évidemment avec
un respect des grandes règles qui sont
celles auxquelles nous sommes tous
attachés du développement durable du
protection la protection de la
biodiversité
mais il y à là dans notre constitution
des perspectives dont jeunes autres
qu'elles sont déjà ouvertes mais pas
utilisés et que les habilitation
législative qui sont permis depuis la
loi de 2000
2 3 dans la vision constitutionnelle de
2003 il a fallu attendre six ans avant
une première collectivité en
l'occurrence la région guadeloupe
sollicite une habilitation législative
et qui a un champ là qui est à changer
inexploité qui devrait permettre sur des
questions comme celle du schéma minier
d'apporter des réponses sur la question
scolaire j'en ai dit un mot évidemment
je vous rejoins et et le problème que
vous avez trouvé en guyane est le même à
mayotte par exemple je pense qu'il faut
qu'on fasse oeuvre d'imagination sur ce
sujet en guyane j'ai proposé la création
d'une agence de la vie scolaire pour
mutualiser aussi ces questions de
d'organisation et fasse que des
transports scolaires sur ces questions
il faut qu'on trouve des outils de
gestion commune de gestion partagée de
ses problématiques qui ne peuvent pas
laisser un maire face à un problème
tellement lourd que il est obligé de
construire
x groupe scolaire ou classe par an parce
qu'il n'y arrive pas on a la même
problématique à mayotte l'état vous avez
sans doute pu le constater fait un
effort conséquent mais des moyens
construit des établissements mais
évidemment il ya une espèce de course
qui se résoudra sans doute aussi par une
coopération régionale renforcée
je plaide pour la guyane par exemple
pour un une
un contrat de développement franco
surinamiens pour toute la région est
ouest de la guyane et que les questions
sanitaires les questions de transport
les questions de gestion de déchets les
questions de scolarité puisse est géré
en collaboration avec le suriname et que
la scolarisation des enfants se fassent
pas simplement avec une pression
migratoire qui encore une fois n'a pas
vraiment de sens mais une politique de
coopération régionale intelligente à
l'échelon du bassin de vie qui
d'ailleurs est très cohérent et très
fermé puisqu'il est limité par la forêt
et qui donc doit permettre d'avoir
d'avoir cet atout là sur ces questions
sur l'octroi de mer moi je suis
évidemment très en phase avec l'idée de
dire qu'il faut qu'on ait une position
claire moi je souhaite qu'ils aient une
position claire qu'ils puissent
s'exprimer à l'occasion de ces états
généraux et qu'on puisse vis-à-vis de
bruxelles à côté de bruxelles en face de
bruxelles contre bruxelles
éventuellement se battre sur cette
question la question de l'octroi de mer
et et est une question plus large
quelles ressources pour les
collectivités locales d'outre-mer et
comment trouver la ressource la plus
pérenne la plus garanti et la plus juste
c'est un vrai débat sur lequel
évidemment les éclaircissements que vous
pourrez nous apporter nous seront
extrêmement utiles sur le développement
jeu je vous rejoins et je terminerai là
dessus sur les questions de deux des
eaux du potentiel je crois qu'il ya un
potentiel absolument considérable pour
faire du développement endogène que ce
potentiel il mérite d'abord qui est une
volonté et qui est une stratégie de
développement local qui soit mis en
place
je pense que la lodeom nous donne déjà
les pistes on détecte en cinq secteurs
porteurs pour le développement local je
les rappelle les nouvelles technologies
la grosse production
le tourisme la recherche et l'énergie et
l'environnement
voilà déjà cinq secteurs clés keeper qui
peuvent permettre de faire du
développement local
il faudra résoudre ensuite la question
du conflit de conflits de l'espace parce
que qui veut dire développement local
veut dire mobilisation de l'espace et
entre l'urbanisation la nécessité de
construire de logements le maintien de
la biodiversité le développement de
nouvelles filières agricoles ou de
nouvelles zones d'activités pour
accueillir l'activité il va à la voir là
des conflits de gestion territoriale
qu'il faudra traiter
je pense qu'il faut que nous ayons
absolument pour chacun de nos
départements
un outil foncier qui soit l'outil
foncier partagé dans lequel on retrouve
les collectivités locales et l'état et
que cet outil foncier est un acteur
majeur non seulement de la préservation
mais aussi de la mobilisation du foncier
en fonction des objectifs qui ont été
déterminés et enfin sur le développement
local
j'ai suggéré et nous y travaillons avec
la datar la mise en place dans chacun
des départements d'outre-mer d'un
commissaire au développement local et à
la production locale
ce commissaire à l'image des
commissaires à la réindustrialisation
qui sont mises en place dans les bassins
frappé par les difficultés économiques
ces commissaires au développement et à
la production locale aurait pour mission
à côté du préfet pendant une période
limitée que je propose de limiter à
trois années de mettre en place des
filières professionnelles sur les sujets
de développement endogène de mettre en
place des stratégies de développement
sur ces filières de rechercher les
investisseurs nécessaire est de garantir
que les professions ce soit le mieux
organisé possible je pense par exemple à
la filière bois en guyane qui est une
filière tout à fait importante qu'il
faut organisé structuré sur sur ces
questions l'idée de ces commissaires au
développement et à la production locale
viendrait appuyer cette volonté de faire
du développement économique endogène
enfin monsieur le rapporteur je suis
heureux que vous soyez revenu avec un
autre gars vous ayez changer de regard
sur l'autre mère je crois qu'il y a dans
ce regard croisé entre la métropole et
l'outre-mer
une grande partie de nos difficultés
qu'il y a beaucoup de malentendus et de
mal vu si j'ose dire au sens
étymologique du terme et que nous avons
aussi un travail à faire
d'explications mais dans un sens comme
dans l'autre
d'explication à l'échelon de la
métropole des réalités qui effectivement
font que quand vous voulez appeler le 18
pour appeler les pompiers
au fin fond de la forêt guyanaise vous
êtes sur une incohérence
mais je le dirai aussi d'explication
vis-à-vis de nos compatriotes
d'outre-mer que l'idée qui était un
combat politique très important qui a
été une mobilisation très forte de du
droit commun de l'égalité de traitement
est une idée sur laquelle il faut se
battre sur les moyens mais pas forcément
sur leur application et que l'égalité
absolue telle qu'elle a été prôné
pendant des années peut arriver à créer
des aberrations et que l'adaptation des
politiques publiques n'est pas jouée
l'inégalité mais jouer au contraire la
réalité moi je me suis heurté très
souvent depuis ses 14 mois à des
réflexions du genre ah oui mais on ne
sera plus on sera plus à égalité avec
avec le reste du territoire
je crois qu'on peut gérer une égalité
qui permettent par d adaptation
intelligente vous l'avez cité sur le
schéma minier on colle cité sur la
politique d'immigration
on peut le site et sur les modalités
d'enseignement qui ne sont pas une
rupture d'égalité mais au contraire une
adaptation
de bon sens des politiques publiques à
des spécificités locales qu'on ne
retrouve nulle part ailleurs
il y a dans ce débat si j'ose dire une
conviction à partager dans un sens comme
dans l'autre
pour faire en sorte que évidemment on
puisse avancer voilà les quelques
réponses que je voulais vous apporter je
dois vous dire que sur vos réflexions
sur leur forme sur leur réalisme et leur
brutalité bienveillante je vous rejoins
à 99% et ça rejoint l'idée l'analyse que
je me suis fais moi même depuis
maintenant un peu plus d'un an des
réalités des difficultés des défis qui
nous attendent vers une autre main et
nous avançons juste de précisions sur
ministre vous nous confirmer que
concernant les habilitations demandé il
ya que la région guadeloupe qui est
demandé une habilitation à ce jour au
titre de la possibilité ouverte dans
l'article 73 de la constitution depuis
sa révision en 2003 il n'y a à ma
connaissance je parle sous contrôle de
mes collaborateurs que la région
guadeloupe qui est sollicitée qui a
obtenu cette habilitation dans la lodeom
une habilitation à pas légiférer c'est
pas le terme et intervenir sur le champ
législatif it off est d'accord parfait
parce que j'avais cru comprendre que
cala marty qu'on ait demandé à mme ida
sûr je pars aujourd'hui à la martinique
y ait un débat qui s'est ouvert sur la
question des transports
mais il n'y a pas eu de demande formelle
très bien je ne dis pas que ce débat
n'existe pas mais en demande formelle
délibérative d'une assemblée pour
solliciter une habilitation dans ce
domaine il n'ya que la guadeloupe la
martinique on sait pas ce que je voulais
m'en suis ouvert avec le président
claude lise qui est une réflexion menée
sur les transports je pense d'ailleurs
ça me permet de dire un mot sur la
politique des transports pour ma part je
pense que en matière de transport il
faut aussi qu'on réfléchisse à une
organisation cohérente
on a un syndicat des transports en
ile-de-france pour 11 millions
d'habitants
il serait peut-être bien d'essayer de
voir comment territoire par territoire
on peut éviter le morcellement des
autorités de transport et avoir une
autorité unique de transport
je pense d'ailleurs que le débat en
martinique c'est de savoir si
l'habilitation est demandée par le
conseil général ou par le conseil
régional sur ce sujet et que les
délibérations qui existent pour
l'instant ne nous précise pas quelle est
la collectivité qu'il faut réhabiliter
donc on est prêt en habilité une
profonde habilités de parfaite et je
voulais vous préciser quelque chose
concernant l'octroi de mer faut savoir
que bruxelles on a vendu le pôle mer à
bruxelles comme et non pas compétent
financement des collectivités
territoriales les communes mais comme un
dispositif susceptible de développer la
création d'entreprise et de et par
conséquent l'emploi et que les rapports
du monde fait pour la pérennisation de
l'emploi de mer doivent viser à
démontrer que le dispositif et m
est il pertinent en matière de création
d'emplois et donc de création
d'entreprise
voilà je passais par là tout de suite
art david assouline quel rôle est
d'abord et puis
oui je me suis le ministre
en revenant du parti de ce voyage
puisque j'étais guadeloupe martinique
moi aussi je frappé par plusieurs choses
et notamment l'écart qu'on a pu
constater j'ai pu constater entre des
interlocuteurs entrepreneurs chercheurs
travailleurs pêcheurs par exemple le
volontarisme qu'il dégage le dynamisme
courage souvent la force de travail et
le fait que tout de même des indicateurs
multiples sont vraiment rouge et c'est
rare parce que dans des sociétés qui
subissent de telles crises sociales en
général ça d'état ensuite sur l'ensemble
de ceux qui doivent agir qui ont plutôt
les bras ballants je sens au contraire
beaucoup de volontarisme et de dynamisme
et caen pour finir à la martinique
on a des responsables importants
d'administration de l'état où l'insee
qui nous disent de façon nette après des
questions que à la martinique
le problème n'est pas de savoir combien
mais quand on atteindra essai sur
cinquante mille chômeurs et dix mille
entreprises qui ferment on peut se dire
que quand même on n'est pas dans le
temps long alors que la crise a révélé
qu'il ya un promu le développement un
problème de vision sur les dix vingt ans
qu'il faut travailler sur le fond les
structures tout ce que font peut-être en
tous les cas veulent faire les états
généraux une autre réflexion des futures
lois mais je me dis que si dans les six
mois
les outils pour rebondir
dire le fait que cinquante mille
chômeurs dix mille entreprises qui
ferment sur quelle base on repart tout
peut être par terre et est-ce qu'il ne
pourrait pas y avoir
dépendamment des différences de vision
quand on est de la métropole à bahreïn
il ya aussi une preuve de tant les
ressentis ce problème de temps est-ce
qu'on le temps législatif qui permet de
faire les choses sur le fond et
l'urgence absolue de faire que des
choses se maintiennent pour pouvoir
rebondir
est-ce que vous n'envisagez pas quand
même quelque chose qui ressemble à un
plan d'urgence exceptionnelle est assez
massif pour faire que ça tienne des six
mois l'année de créer ce qu'on connaît
dans le monde en france qui sera plat
bas peut-être de façon pas peut-être de
façon très brutale j'ai été frappé de
ces deux choses et du fait que peut-être
que si les états généraux ne sont pas
tous les institutions qu'on a rencontrés
y participent
on peut pas dire que la population est
mobilisée autour des états généraux
alors qu'elle s'est mobilisée sur
d'autres choses
y'a pas longtemps et que
peut-être que c'est la dichotomie entre
cette urgence il faut sur la question de
l'emploi
quelles sont la formation des jeunes sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat
quelque chose qui relance la machine et
qui empêche que les collectivités qui
vont de plus en plus mal et à souffrir
encore plus parce que il y aura plus de
prestations sociales plus de 2 de charge
avec une telle situation
voilà ma question est nette n'est-il pas
l n'avez vous pas la conscience qu'il ya
entre la fin des états généraux octobre
comité interministériel et de là
peut-être certainement du travail
législatives que les législatives que
vous déciderez quelque chose qui est non
alors que dès maintenant il faut
investir massivement pour que ça tienne
d'ici là
écoutez ça fait plaisir de vous entendre
parce que quand je me suis battu pour
dire qu'il fallait voter la lodeom à
tout prix et par attendre des états
généraux c'est parce que j'étais sur
cette réflexion là et quand y compris
d'ailleurs contre l'avis de quelques
parlementaires qui disait nous comprend
pas pourquoi vous voulez voter une loi
et ensuite faire des états généraux il y
avait une urgence et cette urgence
évidemment il faut des réponses de très
court terme les états généraux je les
dis c'est le cadre structurel il faut
des réponses de conjoncture alors ces
réponses qu'elles sont elles d'abord on
a mis en place ce qu'on appelait le plan
corail qui est un plan massif de remords
at war sur les dettes fiscales et les
dettes sociales des entreprises de
d'effacement de dette sociale pour
beaucoup d'entreprises de mesures de
relance de l'activité touristique je
faisais le bilan de la première mesure
de relance l'activité touristique les
les plus gros tours opérators nous
disent que ils ont donné aujourd'hui 6 %
de réservations plus que l'année
dernière à la même date sur les périodes
des semaines qui viennent et des mois
qui viennent
grâce à ces dispositifs donc il ya des
mesures sur ces sujets il ya le fonds
exceptionnel d'investissement de
l'outre-mer où nous avons 165 millions
d'euros qui sont posés sur la table des
collectivités locales aujourd'hui c'est
pas des mesures demain c'est fait nous
avons les mesures de la loi de
développement économique de l'outre-mer
qui s'applique dès cette année au 1er
juillet jeux pour les mesures de baisses
de charges et dès cette année pour les
mesures pour les entreprises je ne sais
pas quels sont les chefs d'entreprise
que vous avez vu je ne sais pas d'où
sort ce chiffre de dix mille disparition
d'entreprises
les farfelus il sort d'un esprit farfelu
parce qu'il n'est fondée sur aucune
évaluation
personne ne peut avoir cette évaluation
j'ai passé encore récemment beaucoup de
temps avec les services de l'état en
charge de ces questions personne
personne personne ne peut dire où
prévoir dix mille 15 mille 5000
fermetures d'entreprises s'est fondé sur
un sentiment sur une une projection
dans l'avenir de 2,2 de jantes au delà
c'est le medef qui dit ça en tout cas
moi c'est le medef qui le premier l'a
dit ensuite peut-être qu'il a qu'il a
essaimé dans des esprits sur ce sujet
qui dit il y aura après la crise sociale
il y aura après la crise sociale 10000
fermetures d'entreprises moi j'ai eu
beau interrogé tous les services de
l'état les services de l'iedom qu'est la
banque de france de l'autre maire les
services de fiscaux les services du tpg
personne n'est capable d'anticiper jeu
je ne dis pas que c'est pas vrai je dis
que c'est farfelu parce que c'est fondé
sur rien pourquoi 10000 pourquoi pas
trente mille et ben si ça services de
l'état il faut que le trouver parce que
je suis là et il mais je le lire avec
atteint même 7 vous pouvez me le donner
à voir le rapport je suis baissé sur
tout un service de l'état trop proche du
medef cela existe en particulier outre
mer bah écoutez ça existe sur ce sujet
d'où les d'où l'intérêt d'avoir des
services d'état qui sont capables de
faire des évaluations et qui sont
capables de ne pas aller chercher leurs
chiffres aux mauvaises source
donc on a des mesures qui sont des
mesures d'urgence sur ce sujet
les mesures de la lodeom que vous avez
voté sont extrêmement puissante
une entreprise qui ne va plus payer
cette année
cette année de taxe professionnelle à
hauteur de 80% de foncier bâti et
d'impôt sur les sociétés je faisais le
point avec une entreprise dans le
secteur du tourisme qui à 120 salariés
ces six cent mille euros cette année
d'économiser pour cette entreprise c'est
pas l'année prochaine c'est dé la
trésorerie de cette année
si vous y ajoutez les baisses de se
charge si vous ajoutez les mesures que
j'évoquais du plan corail si vous y
ajoutez l'investissement massif en
matière de plan de relance alors
effectivement fait ensuite les
collectivités locales puissent mettre en
oeuvre les dispositifs c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que sur le financement du plan
de relance nous n'avons pas on était
très large dans les critères on n'a pas
dit il faut que vous apportiez on a été
on a monté jusqu'à 75% les financements
de l'état pour que les projets puissent
démarrer si vous y ajoutez en plus le
résultat d dès la mise en place
anticipée par exemple du est resté à qui
est le dispositif qui va être mise en
place au mois de juillet les premiers
versements au mois de juillet cette
année
l'état va investir dans une relance
quelque part de la consommation qui est
une demande je crois que j'ai entendu
sur certains bancs des assemblées
parlementaires 233 millions d'euros
en outre mer 233 millions d'euros dans
les économies ultramarines
dès cette année ce qui va avoir un effet
sur l'économie qui est en effet
considérable considérable ses 233
millions d'euros qui vont être investis
donc évidemment nous avons bien
conscience que le nouveau modèle que
nous appelons de nos voeux ne peut pas
être construit si la période de crise et
être forte que moi moi je je vous
rejoins en ce sens qu'il y a une énergie
une envie de s'en sortir qui est un
élément positif qui lie à une
conjoncture économique internationale et
une conjoncture locale qui évidemment a
amené des difficultés mais que nous
essayons de mettre en place toutes les
mesures
ur à très court terme pour faire en
sorte évidemment de conforter je
rappelle que la loi de développement
économique de l'outre-mer c'est 1
milliard 500 millions d'euros au profit
de l'économie et du logement la loi
girardin qui s'appliquait jusqu'à il ya
quelques jours c'était un milliard trois
cents millions d'euros donc cette année
il y aura cet apport massif qui sera
fait et je ne compte pas dans ce
milliard 500 millions les 233 millions
d'euros due est resté à qui sont en plus
en investissement donc vous voyez qui
elle a une volonté évidemment de
répondre à ce qui vous a frappé est
mobilisé et moi je vais pratiquement
chaque mois dans chacun des territoires
pour faire le point avec les services de
l'état
j'étais il ya quinze jours en guadeloupe
avec par exemple médiateur du crédit qui
est une des dispositions qui sont aussi
des dispositions nationales qui
s'applique aussi là-bas et le médiateur
du crédit était très surpris de ne pas
avoir de dossier de ne pas avoir de
dossier et vérification faite c'était
pas parce que l'information n'était pas
passé c'était non c'était simplement
parce qu'il n'y avait pas d' entreprise
qui
avec les besoins sur ce sujet là on a le
médiateur s'est posé la question on
s'est posé la question on à moi j'ai
demandé à ce qu'on relance la
communication sur ces sujets là mais il
y a aussi des réalités économiques qui
mérite à mon sens d'être regardé de très
près et je serai très intéressé de
savoir quel est le service de l'état qui
a pu vous donner ce chiffre farfelu des
10000 disparition d'entreprises parce
que parce que sincèrement j'ai entendu
ce chiffre non mais non mais bien sûr
mais j'ai entendu ce chiffre dans la
bouche du patronat a sorti de la crise
et j'ai voulu vérifier d'où venait cette
expertise
j'ai bien entendu j'ai entendu ce
chiffre à la sortie de crise et j'ai
demandé aux services de me direz ça
repose sur quoi c'est personne à ce jour
n'a été capable de me dire sur quoi
reposait si ce n'est une déclaration du
medef de la martinique pour lequel il
faut avoir le plus grand respect mais
qui à ma connaissance sofa n'a pas n'a
pas démontré sa réalité alors je vais
très prudent monsieur le sénateur
je je ne souhaite pas qu'il soit enfin
c'est pas je ne veux pas être un oiseau
de mauvais augure aux de bon augure
je pense que ça met le doigt sur nos
difficultés à anticiper à prévoir à
évaluer les les réalités économiques et
sur effectivement une forme de
difficultés de prévisibilité de
prévisions qui n'est pas une bonne chose
pour la gestion de la politique publique
parce qu'évidemment quand on part un peu
dans le brouillard les choses les choses
sont toujours plus difficiles
on y est très très attentif moi j'y
attache une importance très forte et on
a vraiment avec nos outils y et d'hommes
c'est à dire la la banque de france mode
outre-mer asd qui porte toute la
politique d'oseo et les politiques en
faveur des entreprises
on essaye vraiment d'avoir des
indicateurs très très précis pour
mesurer les effets et pour que la
réponse soit pas une réponse à plus tard
en fonction des nouveaux modèles mais
qui est vraiment du sonnant et
trébuchant de cette année et je vous
remercie
mais monsieur minesup concernant
concernant la guadeloupe
le médiateur et on regarde de plus près
parce que il y aussi acquis retirer mais
je crois qu'il ya des difficultés à les
monter alors cédé pas alors il faudrait
pétrole de plus près peut-être décline
voilà c'est ça d'accord parce que
j'avais des questions très beaucoup plus
ponctuelles que celle de notre collègue
david assouline a posé et j'en avais
deux mais l'une a déjà trouvé un début
de réponse grâce au président de notre
mission parce que j'étais étonné que
depuis le début de notre rencontre cet
après midi on parle pas quand même de
l'octroi de mer par rapport aux
interrogations qui se posent à bruxelles
quand même pas évoqués ou pas
suffisamment évoqué mais le président
larcher ya fait non seulement allusion
mais à juste titre référence parce que
quand on sait que 3 de mr cellou est à
peu près 30 à 40 % 40 % de des
ressources pour les communes donc
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui me
paraît fondamental surtout quand on
parle de plan de relance surtout quand
on parle d'investissements
et c'est encore plus difficile quand on
sait qu'il ya 80% je crois des dépenses
de fonctionnement qui sont plus ou moins
liés au personnel
donc c'est le projet la problématique
elle et les lourdes donc là il ya une
vraie question il faut être très
vigilant
la deuxième question concerne l e
le coût de la vie parce que ça quand
même été un des thèmes à partir desquels
les événements qui se sont déroulés à
quelques mois ont démarré bien et on
voit bien parce que j'ai écouté ce que
vous avez dit monsieur le ministre on en
est aujourd'hui si j'ai bien compris ce
que vous avez dit à chercher des
indicateurs fiables de différentiel du
coût de la vie
c'est une commande en quelque sorte que
vous avez passé à l'insee donc je vous
en félicite je vous en remercie je me
dis quand même c'est un peu particulier
qu'on n'ait pas plus d'éléments
statistiques fiables de nom mais sur
ceux qui composent le coût de la vie
alors qu'on sait que c'est quand même
depuis longtemps on en parle avant même
et bien avant ces événements et alors on
avait évoqué ici avec le directeur de la
direction générale de la concurrence la
consommation et la répression des
phrases qu'ils aient des fraudes
s'appelait monsieur gras je crois le
développement de la concurrence et il
nous avait dit à ben pour développer la
concurrence c'est simple il suffit de
développer le nombre de grandes surfaces
bien moi je n'ai pas été vraiment
convaincu par cet argument parce qu'on
l'entend un peu partout même à montereau
voire à 100 soit au 7 mai nous sommes
voisins et néanmoins amis et ils avaient
rêvé je lui avais demandé est ce qu'on
pouvait avoir les comparaisons en nombre
de mètres carrés par habitant grandes
surfaces outre mer par rapport à ce qui
se passe chez nous parce que je suis pas
sûr que la réponse elle soit là donc
pour me résumer je pense qu'il ya un
travail fondamental à faire au niveau
des éléments qui composent les prix et
voir ceux sur lesquels on peut agir et
l'étranglé les armateurs les
transporteurs nous en dit que c'était 3
à 4% donc on n'avait pas grand chose à
gratter
donc est-ce qu'on peut gratter quelque
chose là dessus parce que c'est quand
même très très important oui sur les
questions de coût de la vie
l'insee fait un travail très lourd 1
évidemment on a des indicateurs
j'ai moi même pendant la période où
j'étais fait des relevés entre un
magasin d'une grande marque
pas très loin de ma commune et le même
magasin de la même grande marques elles
mêmes produits et me relever je le tiens
à disposition de ceux qui le souhaitent
sur une centaine de produits dans
cinquante produits de consommation
courante même produit même m
même quand c'était une 30 % d'écart j'ai
fait moi avec mes avec mes
collaborateurs sur ce sujet ce que le
travail que j'ai demandé à lindsay qui
est un travail long et je regrette ce
soit effectivement sinon est un travail
de d'indicateurs complet des habitudes
de consommation
parce que c'est ça la réalité c'est des
habitudes de consommation du mode de vie
qui fait que quelques elles sont les
dépenses d'un foyer moyen en guadeloupe
et quelles sont les dépenses du même
foyer moyen en métropole les caisses qui
rentre dans tout ça surtout cette
question donc cf travail évidemment qui
est un travail très très très important
mais on a est déjà un certain nombre
d'éléments
je pense que l'avis que doit rendre le
la haute autorité de la concurrence doit
nous donner d'autres éléments sur ce
sujet ça me permet d'ailleurs de
d'apporter une réponse à ce qui a été
dit tout à l'heure par votre rapporteur
sur la nécessité nous sommes dans un
système où d'ailleurs souvent c'est pas
forcément d'ailleurs appréhendé comme ça
vu de l'outre-mer mais les prix sont
libres donc qui a plus de contrôle des
prix l'état n'a plus de services de
contrôle des prix les prix sont libres
simplement ce qu'on doit avoir c'est un
service de la transparence pour
comprendre la formation des prix on l'a
compris par exemple sur l'essence on a
fait ce travail lourd sur le prix de
l'essence qui est un travail qui a été
fait par l'inspection des finances et
sur ce sujet j'ai maintenant mois après
ce travail une idée claire sur la
décomposition du prix de l'essence la
formation du prix de l'essence
le prix sortie de la raffinerie de lire
le coût de la raffinerie
le prix du mode de distribution il faut
savoir que en guadeloupe il ya 115
stations-services et 1200 pompiste ou
1100 pompéi ce soit en moyenne dix par
stations service et que donc ça a une
incidence sur sur sur le prix donc je
crois que le travail qui est le nôtre le
travail qui sera je pense celui de
l'état dans des
service réorganiser c'est d'être le
garant de la transparence parce que je
sais pas si la concurrence baisser les
prix oui normalement les économistes
disent m'enfin faut voir jusqu'à quel
niveau mais je suis sûr qu'une chose
c'est que la transparence elle permet de
faire baisser les prix et que on a un
devoir de transparence nous avons mis en
place à titre expérimental anne marie
payet le sait à la réunion un chariot
type c'est à dire que chaque mois la
direction départementale la concurrence
et de la répression des fraudes va
relever dans toutes les grandes surfaces
de la réunion une liste de produits
qu'elles mêmes qu'est le chariot type et
publie simplement les évolutions de prix
bon eh bien depuis que nous avons mis en
place ce thermomètre on s'est aperçu
d'abord que la concurrence jouait entre
les grandes surfaces et que les prix en
tout cas ceux de ce chariot était en
diminution alors comme on s'est dit que
comme il était publié il devait faire un
effort purement sur ces prix là on a
pris la décision d'avoir des prix pub
des prix publiée et puis dans le chariot
sans produit dont on ne donnerait pas
les caractéristiques mais dont on
mesurait hausse et des prix voilà ce que
peut faire un service mais il a fallu si
j'ose dire réorganiser les directions
départementales avoir des gens dont 7 et
pâle métier initial pour les mettre sur
ces logiques et je crois que dans les
débats sur le modèle économique avoir
des indicateurs et avoir des services de
l'état qui garantit sa transparence et
qui montre la réalité des prix je
voudrais livre est juste une anecdote si
vous le permettez
on m'avait dit et c'est le responsable
du port autonome de guadeloupe qui
m'expliquait que vraiment un conteneur
qui faisait shanghai le havre était
facturé 750 euros que le même conteneur
qui faisait à peu près la même distance
c'est à dire le havre pointe à pitre
était facturé 2500 euros j'avais besoin
de comprendre
je vais donc été rencontrés l'entreprise
qui est d'ailleurs une entreprise
voilà qui est d'ailleurs une entreprise
qui est la troisième mondiale et qu'elle
fournisseur unique qui m'a donné une
partie de l'explication alors je ne sais
pas assez mais en m'expliquant que il y
avait d'abord le souhait des
distributeurs des antilles d'avoir
quatre lieux de chargement en métropole
et que s'il y avait qu un seul lieu de
chargement sa moindre s'abaisserait les
prix qui avaient ensuite une volonté
parfaitement légitime d'avoir des
livraisons plus rapide et que donc le
bateau ne pouvait pas faire du
cabotinage vers l'afrique ce qui lui
aurait aussi permis de se remplir plus
est baissé les prix etc enfin comme de
de cabotage pardon cabotinage fait autre
chose
pardon je vois qu'il ya des spécialistes
cabotinage du cabotage et et enfin
dernier point ce fameux bateau repartant
avec des bananes nécessitait un certain
nombre d'aménagements qui faisait que
c'était des bateaux spécifique qui
étaient fabriqués pratiquement pour le
coup et qui avait dit je ne sais pas si
ça correspond à la totalité du
différentiel de prix mais en tout cas je
pense que un des rôles est une des
missions de l'état cessera sur ces
sujets là de faire la transparence de
montrer la réalité les cheveux des
choses est de traquer au maximum les
excès ou les abus quand ils peuvent se
dissimuler dans des niches où chacun
vient évidemment caché quelque part des
des abus qui pèse sur les prix y'a un
travail extrêmement important à faire
sur ce sujet on a besoin d'indicateurs
moi je n'ai pas aujourd'hui l'indicateur
du nombre de mètres carrés de surfaces
commerciales par habitant comparées
entre 1
m voilà mais je ne vais pas comparer
avec un département de même importance
sur ce sujet voilà toute une série de
choses que le nouveau service ou de la
nouvelle direction de l'évaluation du
secrétariat d'état doit être capable de
nous fournir pour qu'on ait pour qu'on
essaie indicatif et c'est variable d'un
département à l'autre
non mais vous complétez monsieur le
ministre est là pour notre sport c'est
bien c'est très bien mais de système
libéral et ne peut aussi la concurrence
qui régule les prix qui établit les prix
si vous êtes en concurrence ces
anarchistes un petit peu ce que n'ont
vécu pendant mon temps sur la desserte
maritime de l'île des antilles
il n'y a pas de concurrence les amateurs
sont venus ici aux a reçu ils ont fait
de très belles déclarations ils ont dit
qu'ils avaient concurrence nous sommes
allés sur le terrain
en guadeloupe comme à la barre des 10 ce
sont des thèmes honda trouvent ils sont
la position tellement d'obus note qu'il
n'ya pas de concurrence
en fait alors qui peut expliquer les
choses mais il fournit des chiffres
qu'on trouvera dans le rapport qui
convergent pour dire alors ça c'est à
vérifier que le coût du transport au
fond est marginal sur un litre de lait
j'ai le souvenir 10 centimes 10 centimes
si le président me reconnais mais justin
jules même débat sur l'essence
quand je voyais les pétroliers et
l'entreprise sahara il m'expliquait que
le prix de l'essence était peu très
élevé à cause des distributeurs et des
pompistes est vraiment c'était
scandaleux qui avait une situation je
dis pas que c'est ce que je disais moi
je dis que c'est ce qu'ont expliqué et
parallèlement quand je voyais les autres
acteurs il m'expliquait que vraiment
c'était très raisonnable mode de
distribution mais que les prix étaient
très élevées parce que le pétrolier au
passage faisait des marges indues
la mission qu'on a envoyés nous a permis
de voir quoi avec chacun avait un peu
raison est un peu tort et que
effectivement cumulé au bout du système
il y avait une situation qui était très
préjudiciable au consommateur qui était
au bout du tuyau si j'ose dire mais
qu'il y avait effectivement dans
l'ensemble du dispositif matière à faire
des progrès que quand on ajouté les
progrès des uns au progrès des autres on
finissait par avoir une situation qui
qui redeviennent plus normal c'est c'est
un des éclairages qui nécessite à mon
sens qu'on puisse avoir sur le maximum
de sujets ces outils de la transparence
pour pouvoir voir la réalité des choses
est évidemment comme on va le faire sur
le prix de l'essence vis-à-vis des
pétroliers ou comme il faudra peut-être
qu'il y ait cette réflexion à l'échelon
des territoires vis-à-vis du mode de
distribution
eh bien chacun essaye de trouver des
efforts là où il doit être fait on a
évidemment une obligation de
transparence
chi chi chi chi à qui a beaucoup manqué
qui est à la source de beaucoup des
critiques de beaucoup d insatisfaction
et je le dirai de beaucoup des dérives
bien sûr tout à fait et le cabotage donc
n'explique pas tout les cabotinages dr
adjobi l'ipad
oui monsieur le ministre j'aimerais vous
poser de questions d'abord sur le
service militaire adapté vous voulez
doubler le nombre de places dans les
différentes antennes et c'est une
décision qui me réjouit puisque je
réclame depuis plusieurs années dans mon
rapport sur le budget le développement
de ce dispositif qui est vraiment très
performant qui donne d'excellents
résultats
à tel point que le premier ministre du
gouvernement précédent a souhaité
l'introduire en métropole sous une autre
appellation mais si mes souvenirs sont
bons je crois qu'on devra atteindre cet
objectif avec les mêmes équipements et à
budget constant
alors est ce code dans ces conditions le
dispositif va garder sa même efficacité
ensuite vous souhaitez développer le
télé-enseignement alors j'aimerais
savoir si cette méthode sera celle qui
sera privilégiée aussi à mayotte pour
combler le déficit d'établissements
scolaires ou à cause de l'immigration
clandestine qu'on n'arrive pas à
endiguer
il existe un système de scolarité par
rotation certains élèves viennent à
l'école le matin d'autres l'après midi
et c'est quand même le seul endroit de
france où on peut observer cela vous
oubliez tout complété avec la première
question de bethmale payet sait que des
reçus ici le colonel qui s'occupe de la
leucémie et sema il a dit qu'on
multiplie par deux à six mille
aphatie fins militaires mais qu'on
diminue par la balle d'un même temps à 6
mois 9 3 6 mois et qu'il ne voyait pas
comment il aurait pu accomplir sa
mission d' avec le temps aussi réduit
voilà côté je ne sais pas ce que vous a
dit le colonel mais en tout cas il n'est
plus il n'est plus en fonction sur le
bcma dès cet été et est à ma
connaissance c'est encore les les
ministres et le gouvernement qui décide
et pas les hauts fonctionnaires
fusse-t-il des généraux donc le sm a
sera bien doubler pour être porté à 6000
et dans le budget de l'année 2010 vous
verrez les traductions budgétaire de
cette augmentation étant entendu que
cette augmentation était annoncé par le
président de la république qu'elle se
porte sur trois années budgétaires parce
qu'il faut évidemment je le dis pour
anne marie payet le temps de mobiliser
là où c'est nécessaire les locaux en
sachant que moi j'ai visité toutes les
implantations du et ses maquis en
matière d'implantation ne sont pas les 3
elles ont toutes des implantations qui
sont très vastes donc sur les trois
années de 2010 2011 2012 le sm à verra
sa capacité portée à 6000 et les moyens
financiers seront adaptés à cette
augmentation
la seule réflexion qui est menée c'est
de savoir s'il faut garder un schéma de
12 mois pour tout le monde puisque ces
douze mois ou pas ca 9 mois pour
certains qui ayant plus de capacité à
s'insérer pourrait bénéficier d'une
insertion professionnelle plus rapide en
faisant neuf mois de formation militaire
c'est le seul débat qui a lieu à
l'intérieur que nous n'avons pas encore
tranché
si évidemment nous avions demandé au
général frétille c'est lui que vous avez
à rencontrer alors si c'est un colonel
sur ce sujet si évidemment nous avons
demandé de le faire à moyens constants
ça n'avait pas de sens parce qu'on tue l
esprit du cema je vous confirme donc
officiellement que les moyens du essaima
seront augmentés à due proportion pour
garder un outil le plus efficace
possible
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il faudra pas
se poser dans tel territoire la question
de la rationalisation de ses
implantations parce que dans certains
endroits il ya des implantations
multiples ce qui ne veut pas dire et
c'est ma volonté que nous n'ouvrirons
pas de nouvelles implantations pour le
sema je souhaite que nous puissions
mettre en place un schéma à wallis et
futuna et que nous puissions ouvrir une
implantation à wallis et futuna et que
nous puissions implanter une structure
du cema à saint martin pour que les
jeunes saint martinois puissent eux
aussi bénéficient de ce dispositif donc
là dessus il ya vraiment une volonté de
mettre les moyens budgétaires
nécessaires pour doubler le nombre de
jeunes accueillis dans des conditions
qui soient celles d'aujourd'hui
puisqu'elles ont montré leur performance
je rappelle que le s est massée 75 %
d'insertion professionnelle au bout du
au bout du dispositif est que les jeunes
pendant leur temps dans les deux
passages sont rémunérés ce sont des
jeunes qui touche une rémunération
ils sont formés et rémunère le deuxième
point sur le télé enseignement ça fait
partie des réflexions qui sont
évidemment ouvertes sur ces questions
moi c'est une piste que je suggère de
travailler et
là dessus nous sommes sur une approche
qui qui ne fallait donner au début de la
réflexion
ça y est c'est en 3d d'un président au
nom de monsieur le ministre on reviendra
pas sur le constat je crois que nous
sommes tous d'accord plus ou mois sur le
constat je crois que le rapporteur
monsieur d'obliger a bien résumé en et
je vous félicite peut-être que pour pour
vous aider faudrait-il peut-être
proposer au président de la république
le cool que le comité interministériel
se tient dans les dents comme ça vos
collègues ministres vont se rendre
compte de la réalité des départements
d'outre-mer
donc au delà du constat je pense que
j'affirme aussi qu'elle crée un problème
au niveau donc des des services
déconcentrés de l'état
effectivement on appela systématiquement
les mêmes analyses même résultats des
évaluations et c'est vrai que entre ce
que nous dit le directeur pendant
l'exemple de du pôle emploi qui
précisait qui est d'ailleurs ses traits
figure dans le compte rendu
une diminution du pib par tête
d'habitant de 10 points en dix ans de
tpg nous disait que effectivement ce
chiffre était est pour reprendre votre
expression farfelue il ya quelque chose
à harmoniser quelque part parce que si
on n'a pas la même analyse
forcément on pourra pas apporter les
mêmes réponses alors sur les réponses
sur les réponses proposées
je crois que le collègue assouline a
raison de distinguer deux types de
réponses des réponses à court terme
parce qu'effectivement il y a urgence
dans les départements d'outre-mer
le sentiment qui en résulte c'est que
déjà nous avons un taux de chômage qui
est relativement élevé plus élevé que la
moyenne nationale
à titre d'exemple il est de l'ordre de
22 à 23% guyane ca augmenter autour de
25% aux antilles je crois que c'est la
réunion qui détient le record 25% et je
ferai pas non plus le zoom sur le taux
de chômage était jeune mais si vous le
connaissez
parce que vous avez une parfaite
connaissance de des réalités en
outre-mer et dès lors l'enjeu dit que
les réponses ne sont pas adaptés c'est
que vous dites que la lodeom est une
réponse j'espère est une réponse mais
n'est pas la réponse n'est pas la
réponse et les insuffisante
tout simplement parce que quand nous
rencontrons les chefs d'entreprise ils
nous disent bien sûr que la
défiscalisation les exonérations tous
ces éléments vont améliorer leur
trésorerie
mais si en face il n'y a pas deux comme
un nom ça sert à rien amélioré une
trésorerie s'il n'y a pas de commande or
justement nous constatons que dans les
départements d'outre-mer mais comme en
france hexagonale mais davantage dans
les départements d'outre-mer parce que
le tissu économique est tout à fait
différent ce sont les collectivités
locales qui porte l'investissement
alors vous avez annoncé le chiffre de
160 5 millions d'euros sauf que nous
savons très bien que ce montant ne sera
pas mobilisés pour la simple et bonne
raison qu hormis la région martinique
qui est un excédent de 13 millions
d'euros dixit le président du conseil
régional les autres collectivités
locales n'ont pas les moyens financiers
pour après pour apporter les 25%
premièrement parce que les plans de
relance et fléchier dans les domaines
des particuliers dans des particuliers
en particules en guyane à titre
d'exemple à juste titre il s'agit de la
problématique des déchets parce que le
gouvernement français va certainement
payé
43 43 millions de pénalités donc je
prends cet exemple alors que nous avons
des retards en matière de constructions
scolaires
si je prends l'exemple de la commune de
saint laurent du maroni que vous
connaissez très bien vous avez hésité
récemment doit réaliser des groupes
scolaires que les lycées à kourou la
région du en guyane par dans la région
guyane doit livrer sur deux en quatre
groupes scolaires
bref vous voyez bien que nous avons des
difficultés pour à apporter pour co
financer ses opérations donc dès lors
dès lors et là il n'y a pas de réponse à
court terme
voilà pourquoi je dis que la relance de
l'activité économique est en panne
dès lors il n'a pas de réponse sur les
dotations des collectivités locales
on a pointé la question de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement parce qu'on a
qu'est ce qu'ils aient une certaine
disparité en particulier pour les villes
de plus de 10 mille habitants et est de
même dans certains postes
la péréquation ne joue pas et on intègre
toujours pas la question de la
surrémunération ddd 20% des 40% de vie
chère et on voit bien que cette
surrémunération jouent un rôle
fondamental
quand on compare à titre d'exemple la
situation financière des collectivités
locales qui qui est globalement
déficitaire mais on constate que celle
de la réunion par exemple les
collectivités locales de la réunion une
situation financière qui se porte mieux
par rapport aux autres tout simplement
parce que ils ont tous deux
titularisations qui est tout à fait
différent le taux de titularisation à la
river est de l'ordre de 20% alors que ce
taux est de l'ordre de 80% en guadeloupe
martinique et guyane et dès lors cela
donc n'a pas le même impact sur une des
finances des collectivités locales et
par conséquent le taux d'autres photos
de l'ofa l'autofinancement est tout à
fait dans différents donc je crois qu'il
faut apporter une réponse immédiate par
rapport aux finances des collectivités
locales et pour finir grands serments
les filières
bien sûr vous avez rappelé dans les
filières qui ont été retenus dans la
lodeom
mais quid de la filière pêche de la
filière bois de la filière agricole
n'ont pas un gros alimentaires agricoles
ça veut dire comment en sachant si on
prend l'exemple de la guyane il a été
précisé que 0 3% de la surface utile
donc alors que il ya 90 milles 83 86
mille kilomètres carrés on arrive à
peine à satisfaire à peine 20% de la
consommation donc il y à dire qu'il ya
des potentiels qui ne sont pas
exploitées tout simplement parce qu'il
ya un problème de financement de ses
activités notamment de l'agriculture de
la filière bois etc
et pour terminer pour effectivement la
question du potentiel minier
je crois que c'est pas la bonne réponse
en disant il ya la loi de l'habilitation
seule la région guadeloupe sollicités
nous savons très bien que les procédures
sont très lents et par ailleurs et par
ailleurs pour vous donner un exemple de
deux difficultés
rappelez vous que nous avons voté sur la
lodeom
pascal avait dit qu'il fallait inverser
donc dans la hiérarchie des documents le
schéma minier qui s'impose au sart alors
que nous il ya eu des abonnements pour
inverser que le sar s impose au schéma
minier et dès lors vous ai bien compris
je crois qu'il était dit par tous deux
professionnels de de jimmy hunt qui de
par rapport à l'or ou aux autres minier
on sent bien que il ya eu mais mise de
la part de l'état sur ces questions
alors qu'ils ont un potentiel et régis
mans important agissements qui pourrait
financer justement le développement
économique
de la guyane alors on a vu une carte qui
n'est pas officielle mais qui nous a été
présenté à savoir que nos potentiels au
niveau de l'orc est douze fois supérieur
au surinam la guyane regorge de diamants
d'uranium
qu'est ce que nous avons vu encore cuit
bauxite et bien sûr éventuellement donc
du pétrole or nous savons très bien que
nous avons rencontré cette difficulté
quant à la possibilité de fiscaliser ses
activités ou voir même d'augmenter la
taxe aurifère je tiens à rappeler dans
le rapport sur vingt-deux mille euros il
ya que 45 euros 22000 euros le kilo d'or
contre connaissez très bien il ya que 45
euros que donc de défiscaliser alors je
crois que il ya tous ces éléments dans
qui fait qu tivement à revoir mais
surtout j'insiste effectivement entre le
temps législatif
les relativement lent nécessaires pour
restructurer le développement économique
de la guyane et de faire des
départements d'outre-mer pendant et est
tout ce qu'il ya immédiat et pour donner
un dernier exemple nom de ce décalage
je termine le dernier exemple pas pour
ce décalage actuellement et voter la loi
sur l'hôpital
alors qu'en guyane je veux dire ce
secteur est sinistré
très bien merci monsieur oui rapidement
le le fonds exceptionnel
d'investissement les communes et les
collectivités qui ont demandé en
bénéficier se sont engagés à faire les
travaux dans l'année donc je ne veux pas
croire qu'un maire vous êtes nerveux
sumer et déposé un dossier en préfecture
en sachant qu'ils pouvaient pas faire
des travaux et les travaux je démens
formellement l'idée qui serait fléchés
sur une activité plus qu'une autre
il ya des obligations sur le traitement
des déchets il ya d'ailleurs des crédits
spécifiques sur les questions de
traitement de déchets qui n'ont rien à
voir avec le fonds exceptionnel
d'investissement qui sont prévus dans le
cadre du grenelle et le fonds
exceptionnel d'investissement mais je
publierai commune par commune
l'ensemble des aides
et à fonds exceptionnel d'investissement
plan de relance et dotation globale
d'équipement qui sont sur la table des
communes parce que je crois aussi qu'il
faut mettre chacun en face de ses
responsabilités et que quand on dépose
un dossier pour solliciter le fonds
exceptionnel d'investissement au titre
de l'année 2009 au titre du plan de
relance l'on sait parfaitement quelles
sont les règles du jeu donc je ne
voudrais pas s'il ya un seul élu qui
vient expliquer qu'il a déposé un
dossier mais qui savait parfaitement
qu'il pourrait pas faire les travaux
ça me semble être totalement antinomique
tout là-dessus je vous garantis que ces
sommes là sont des sommes qui seront
dépensés dans l'année j'ai d'ailleurs
commencé à poser des premières pierres
de chantier ça démarre par tous donc là
dessus je publierai pour la guyane
commune par commune la liste des travaux
que les maires se sont engagés à faire
on était assez souple on a dit que ça
pouvait monter jusqu'à 75% de
financement et que c'était assez large
que le seul objectif c'était que ça
démarre dans l'année que ce soit et que
ce soit des travaux qu'ils soient
évidemment le producteur d'activité et
d'emploi sur deuxième doc là-dessus
votre vision elle est pas juste monsieur
le sénateur maire deuxième point la
grosse production
c'est la filière halieutique et la pêche
c'est le veut la filière bois c'est
toutes les productions issues de
l'agriculture s'est pas seulement de
l'alimentaire donc les secteurs
prioritaires de la loi de développement
économique
les secteur sur lequel nous voulons
aider à structurer des filières
professionnelles c'est bien ce qui
correspondent à ce que vous avez évoqué
le riz évidemment le
le la filière bois évidemment et
l'agroalimentaire évidemment sur ce qui
est du schéma minier
si je n'ai pas accepté les amendements
qui visaient à dire que le le schéma
d'aménagement régional s'impose au
schéma minier s'est pour une raison
simple que vous connaissez c'est parce
qu'ils étaient inconstitutionnelles et
qu'on ne pouvait pas avoir une
disposition propre un département
d'outre-mer qui soumettent un schéma
d'aménagement régional
un schéma minier qui par nature est un
schéma
à vocation nationale et qui s'imposent
la seule voie possible
je les dis dans l'hémicycle et je le
répète aujourd'hui la seule voie
possible pour faire en sorte que ce
schéma s'impose au sort c'est qu'ils
soient faits par la collectivité sur une
habilitation et ne dit pas parce que ce
n'est pas vrai que ça prend du temps
la région guadeloupe nous a interrogés
au mois de mars sur son habilitation
elle a eu son habilitation au mois de
mai donc ça ne prend pas de temps ce
n'est pas vrai il faut qu'il y ait une
décision une volonté politique
mais si demain la région guyane demande
une habilitation pour réaliser le schéma
guise de de guyane minier le
gouvernement examinera avec avec
rapidité c'est cette demande et
l'habilitation neu neu neu neu ne prend
pas de temps c'est la hausse y est moi
je crois que dans non ce que le travail
des malentendus qu'on peut avoir de part
et d'autre des visions différentes qu'on
peut avoir de part et d'autre il faut
aussi ne pas colporter des choses qui ne
sont pas vraies ce que vous avez dit sur
temps l'utilisation du fonds
exceptionnel d'investissement que les
secteurs de prioritaires dalo des sommes
que le schéma minier ne sont pas des
choses vraies c'est pas des réalités ce
qu'il veut pas dire qu'il ya pas de
problème et tout devient simple etc si
demain la région guyane demande une
habilitation pour réaliser le même le
schéma minier
ça se transforme oies en
en une simplicité biblique mais mais si
on moi je pense comme vous qu'il faut
que ce soit décidée à un échelon local
je pense que alors je ne sais pas quels
sont les schémas ou les cartes que vous
a montré j'ai vu aussi les lobbys du
secteur aurifère qui sont très puissants
on les a vus agir dans la sphère iamgold
eux
ces lobbys là je pense qu'il faut
trouver le juste équilibre évidemment
entre une exploitation intelligente et
durable et une exploitation outrancière
mai mais sur ce sujet moi je suis je
suis très ouvert à vous apporter à
apporter à la guyane des réponses très
pragmatique et à ne pas faire comme l'a
dit est très joliment votre rapporteur
et la guyane sont mis sous une cloche
il faut protéger la nature on en est
tous persuadés et on peut le faire dans
une vision de développement qui qui qui
préserve les intérêts moi je vraiment je
fasse je dis ça moi je suis très ouvert
à son âge très vite très bien et je
passe la parole à jacques gillot nommer
jan oui mais une chronologie et je
respecte eh bien non mais chez les elle
dit les bromide dans l'est dans les dix
minutes qui me reste maintenant parce
que pascal a dit wang innovatie oui
enfin on ira très vite monsieur le
ministre je peux revenir il faut revenir
non je voulais avoir quelques précisions
je suis en septembre de décisions déjà
prises m'enfin qui pose problème
notamment je voulais savoir si
l'application programmée du est restée à
est-ce que renvoie à l'application
anticipée que nous avons demandée pour
le rsa comme savons maintenant que c'est
pas du tout la même chose
d'autant plus que le reste est assez
pour effectivement tous les salariés et
le rsa c'est c'est une autre stratégie
d'ailleurs qui a pratiquement fait
l'unanimité au niveau du parlement
donc je voudrais avoir des précisions
car aujourd'hui nous savons que
vous avez vous avez dit que rester assez
pour trois ans et le rsa nous avions
demandé une application avant 2011
et ça me permet de vous demander les
quelques éléments vous avez déjà du pré
rapport de monsieur de nos collègues
victoria station premier pot
deuxièmement sur quelques mesures assez
rapidement mises en place et pour lequel
on vous avait interrogé lors de l'examen
de la loi sous la valeur économique des
outre-mer c'est sur l'application du
contrat d'autonomie pour les jeunes
effectivement lors de cette discussion
je crois que ça va retenez votre
assentiment il était question qu'on
puisse appliquer rapidement cette mesure
car en fait c'était déjà appliquée pour
les banlieues si tous les jeunes de 16 à
24 ans vous savez qu'il est difficile de
rien et ce sont ces mêmes jeunes là
qu'on trouve sur les barricades lors des
manifestations je sais que depuis hier
et le plan de relance pour l'emploi des
jeunes en insertion des jeunes devraient
commencer mais je voudrais vraiment si
vous pouvez le faire aujourd'hui assez
rapidement nous dire quelles sont
vraiment les mesures concrètes que vous
devez appliquer dans les quelques
semaines ou mois pour ces jeunes et
encore reçu une interpellation du
ministre borloo sur la la les prix de
l'énergie je vous ai souhaité
effectivement que nous restions sur le
système actuel c'est à dire en fait que
nous puissions rester dans la
péréquation nationale et que ne
puissions pas les mêmes vertus
l'ouverture de la concurrence qui
va pénaliser très très largement les
entreprises guadeloupéennes et bien sûr
par la défense de m les particuliers de
la pression oui patients et tu veux
poser la question maintenant après tu
est après tout il s'agit de qui demande
des réponses très urgent donc je vais
très bref je reviens sur le schéma
minier
c'est vrai il est contenu dans la lodeom
il vous avait parlé de la procédure
d'habilitation et annie rosselle
maintenant pêche
ce schéma minier qu'il devait être
élaboré et adopté en décembre 2008
depuis son élaboration qui donne déjà
depuis plus d'une année les activités
minières sont quasiment gelé en guyane
en attente de ce schéma minier
actuellement il a décrié unanimement en
guyane et même s'il fallait faire une
procédure de légalisation comme l'a dit
mon collègue antoinette ça prendrait
beaucoup de temps avant schéma minier il
n'y avait plus de cent artisans locaux
qui travaillait dans l'ordre
actuellement il ne reste plus que quatre
parce que les zones sont déjà sur ce
fameux plan mans sion et jusqu'à
maintenant bon des autorisations ne
peuvent être donnés en attendant que ce
schéma minier soit élaborée donc en
attente
l'adoption de ce schéma minier ou bien
qu'une procédure d'habilitation est ce
que vous pouvez pas donner des
instructions aux services de la drire
pour qu'il recommence à donner des
autorisations de travail à beaucoup
d'artisans locaux qu'actuellement se
retrouvent sans travail alors deuxième
question les outils financiers on en a
beaucoup parlé dans les quatre dom
vous avez fait référence à l'afd qui
intervenait pour le conte d'oseo bdpme
ont attendu de façon unanime aussi
causer oubli des pme les produits de
oséo bdp bdpme n'était pas distribuer
et dans les dom com ils sont distribués
en france donc ça aussi je pense qu'il
faut revoir ce point très important et
hiver ni moins dernier point le plan
corail n'existe pas il existe en
martinique en guadeloupe il existe unis
à la réunion ni ennuyeux très bien
monsieur giraud question va di rupo oui
mais sur le président en question
s'adresse à vous parce que je suis
surpris mais ceux plaidant que vous ayez
visiter les autres îles et mayotte n'a
pas été visité et comment pouvez-vous
dire dans votre rapport
gevrey pour tout de suite couché aux
collectes et rapide
alors le sénat a mis cette mission
commune d'information sous les quatre
départements d'outre-mer quatre
départements de l'est pas encore et
encore goûté quatre départements
maty gbané guyane et réunion et c'est
tous les ans il construit notre notre
diva que ceux des autres études ce que
sur les quatre départements ceci étant
dit il faut dire que c'est des sujets
des prises pensionnat à la suite
d'événements qui ont concerné ces quatre
départements là mais alors la mission
était sous cape département c'est comme
je viens de le dire et c'est pour cette
raison que nous n'avons pas ne sont pas
la meilleure mais cela n'interdit pas
après mais sa dépendance est là à ce
moment de faire une mission
parlementaire cela il faut bien
comprendre que diderot mission
s'inscrivait sur un territoire que vous
paie les quatre départements par
ailleurs il n était pas n'avaient pas
voté à l'époque
donc on pouvait après juger du froid des
mahorais la gauche monsieur sont
d'accord cela de ce 7 septembre c'est
elle
c'était la décision du sénat nous avons
respecté à la lettre
oui
cela permet de satisfaire vue de cette
façon là mais à partir du moment où vous
était quand même au point le sénat
étaient au courant avant de avant de
prendre cette mesure parce que le sénat
a été a été appelé à voter pour la loi
pour le vote pour le référendum du sénat
donc le résultat est inconnue la mission
n'avait pas commencé
bien manger relègue ce qu'il fallait
faire mon cher collègue sénateur cdh
était repris en son temps le président
du sénat pour qu'on était meilleur et ce
sera mes temps libres
ça va des fêtes n'ont pas pu avoir c'est
de cette mission la sublime en terre
voilà je vous dis que je vais essayer de
conclure rsa est resté à monsieur le
président vous savez très bien dans
quelles conditions le est resté a été
mise en place puisque c'était une
revendication forte de la guadeloupe le
est restée assez exactement les mêmes
sommes que le rsa c'est 233 millions
d'euros pour tout l'outre-mer c'est donc
une anticipation des dépenses au titre
de l'aide aux travailleurs pauvres qui
ai fait le rst a fait distribuer sous
forme d'une aide forfaitaire mensuelle
un nombre plus important de salariés que
le serait le rsa puisque le rsa c'est la
même somme d'argent mais qui est
distribuée selon des critères sociaux
je parle du rsa chapeau 1 on s'entendait
assure sur cet aspect des choses
la loi est très claire elle dit qu'à
partir du début 2011 le rsa se mettra en
place outre-mer donc le est resté à et
si j'ose dire une anticipation du rsa et
dans le rapport qu'il vient de remettre
au premier ministre le député victoria
propose qu'on mette à profit l'année et
demie qui nous sépare pour évaluer les
deux dispositifs et que ce soit à terme
soit le rsa qui se substituent
complètement au et reste r ça voudra
dire à ce moment là que l'économie aura
pu faire face aux augmentations de
salaires dans un certain nombre de
circonstances
pour les salariés qui ne bénéficieraient
pas du rsa alors qu'il bénéficiait du et
restèrent soit deuxième solution
le est resté à restera comme étant la
politique des taux bas salaires parce
que l'évaluation aura ou auraient
démontré que c'était une politique
publique qui avait ses vertus soit ce
serait un produit mixte rsa est resté à
qui serait mis en place pour permettre
la transition toutes les options sont
ouvertes
le gouvernement souhaite le faire en
toute transparence et faire en sorte qu
effectivement ce est resté à qui est une
forme de rsa mais appliquée de façon
forfaitaire est systématique et bien
puisse répondre à la crise qui était
quand même son objectif et puis cédé la
place au système le plus avantageux dans
le délai des trois années qui viennent
nous sommes sur les périodes donc 2009
2010 2011 qui sont nos période de
réflexion vous verrez c'est les
préconisations du rapport victoria sur
ce sujet mais on aura évidemment
l'occasion d'en reparler
sur le contrat d'autonomie s'applique
j'ai signé les premiers contrats
d'autonomie à la réunion une
expérimentation qu'est fait des
possibilités de son extension et donc
nous sommes dans le calendrier que j'ai
évoquées dans le cadre de la lodeom sur
les questions de prix je vous rassure y
aura bien on maintiendra un système
propre à l'outre-mer et dans le cadre
des travaux que nous menons ensemble
avec le comité de suivi des prix du
carburant on veut faire évoluer les
choses dans un sens à la fois positif
pour les consommateurs et transparent
comme ça a été évoqué sur la question du
schéma minier je vais évidemment
regarder à nouveau et je retiens votre
suggestion c'est le sénateur
éventuellement de pouvoir donner
quelques autorisations si ce schéma
mettait encore trop de temps à sortir je
vous donnerai des éléments avant l'été
sur cette question là enfin vous avez
des informations erronées puisque
aujourd'hui l'afd distribuer la totalité
des produits oseo bdpme s'est pas érodée
depuis longtemps donc je fous je vous
pardonne mais nous avons veillé en sorte
à ce que life des soit le guichet qui
distribue la totalité des produits oseo
dont il ya plus de il ya plus de
différence et le plan corail
s'appliquera bien en guyane et à la
réunion
il ya eu un temps de décalage était à la
réunion lundi dernier pour vérifier son
application je vous confirme donc que le
plan corail s'appliquera donc dans nos
dom ya simplement un petit délai de mise
en oeuvre d'information notamment des
caisses de sécurité sociale du trésor
public mais les choses sont faites de la
même manière partout effectivement j'ai
constaté comme vous qu'un certain nombre
de guichets n'avait pas encore
l'information et que l'information va
plus vite dans france antilles elle ne
va dans les services de l'état qui de ce
fait ne doivent pas dire france antilles
ce qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle ce
qui veut dire qu'ils sont concentrés sur
leurs dossiers donc je vous confirme
bien que le plan corail s'appliquera en
guyane et à la réunion sans aucune
difficulté enfin je rassure le sénateur
giraud
mayotte n'est pas oublié et je suis sûr
que les réflexions de la mission
viendront aussi éclairer la politique du
gouvernement vis à vis de mayotte
je vous souhaite de vous remercier
monsieur le président vous priez
d'excusés mon obligation de partie mais
vous dire que si vous souhaitez avant la
fin de vos travaux
une nouvelle audition j'y suis
évidemment non seulement favorable mais
j'y serai j'en serais trésor merci 2010
et bien sûr le sujet des lois est très
loin d'être épuisées nous n'avons pas
abordé le problème du logement
mon sociale en particulier le
financement accordé et les collectivités
des opérateurs gratia défaillance des
collectivités territoriales nous n'avons
pas parlé des minima sociaux
nous n'avons pas parlé de votre démarche
concernant la 17ième gains à partir de
deux mois ci pour permettre les crétois
relie versification des sources
d'approvisionnement de nos jours à
nantes et donc il ya de fortes chances
que vous refusiez il ya tant à faire et
à dire encore sur le problème des
outre-mer je vous remercie tous et à
bientôt
là